on va démarrer certains de nos amis ne
vont pas tarder à nous rejoindre
avant de dire quelques mots je voudrais
vous transmettre à tous
un message de Gérard Larcher le
président du Sénat qui s'excuse de ne
pouvoir être là cet après-midi
j'ai tenu donc je m'exprime dans son nom
j'ai tenu à être présent parmi vous et à
vous transmettre à tous et à toutes une
pensée amicale je voudrais remercier le
président caoutchi le président de cette
table ronde et saluer le remarquable
engagement de notre président du groupe
d'amitié francs sucré nos Sénat j'en
fais autant Nadia solo goub elle fait
beaucoup pour notre coopération
décentralisée je tiens à saluer
également Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
d'Ukraine en France et les représentants
des collectivités ukrainiennes présents
par visioconférence
il y a plus d'un an le 24 février 2022
la Russie a attaqué l'Ukraine au delà
des objectifs strictement militaires les
populations civiles des écoles des
maternités des hôpitaux ont été la cible
de la soif de conquêtes russes dans le
but de faire régner la terreur combien
de villes et villages martyrs de famille
ukrainiennes éprouvées et pourtant et
pourtant l'Ukraine continue de résister
plus encore elle est partie à la
reconquête de son territoire souverain
occupé dans ce combat contre l'agresseur
russe les autorités locales ukrainiennes
les gouverneurs les mers en fait preuve
dès les premiers jours de l'agression
d'une capacité de résistance et de
résilience qui force l'admiration ils
n'ont pas faibli depuis lors
fidèles à leur territoire à leur ville à
leur village ils ont refusé d'en livrer
l'accès à l'armée russe ils ont organisé
la résistance la défensive le
ravitaillement les abris pour se
protéger des bombardements ils puisent
dans l'adversité les ressources
nécessaires pour maintenir partout
l'état ukrainien une administration
adaptée aux circonstances et surtout une
assistance à leur concitoyens plusieurs
élus locaux ont été victimes de
l'agresseur russe je veux rendre un
hommage vibrant au président de conseil
régionaux aux mères et élus locaux
ukrainien aux côtés du président
Zelinski ils sont l'âme d'une résistance
qui n'entend rien céder nous pouvons les
applaudir et les remercier
dans les plus graves dangers les
responsables locaux ukrainien ont montré
que les collectivités territoriales
étaient autant d'obstacles élevés face
au péril et de remparts qui protègent à
ce titre le Sénat est fier d'avoir
contribué dès 2015 à la réforme des
collectivités locales et de la
décentralisation en Ukraine en France le
sort de la population
ukrainienne a suscité un élan de
générosité sans pareil depuis des années
partout nos concitoyens à titre
individuels au sein d'associations se
sont montrés solidaires de la souffrance
et du désarroi des Ukrainiens par tous
les mairies les départements les régions
quelle que soit leur appartenance
politique on fourni de façon spontanée
le cadre logistique pour assembler les
bonnes volontés regrouper l'aide la
conditionner puis l'acheminer jusqu'au
frontières extérieures de l'Union
européenne et jusqu'en Ukraine même
partout des Ukrainiens cherchant refuge
ont été accueillis à bras ouverts dans
nos territoires lorsqu'il a fallu
trouver des structures d'accueil
s'assurer de leurs qualités recherchent
des interprètes des cours de langue
concourir à la scolarisation des plus
jeunes et à l'insertion professionnelle
des adultes les collectivités
territoriales françaises ont répondu
présent elles ont fait rayonner le nom
d'une France solidaire mais elles ont
été laissées bien seuls
l'État en France a trop souvent la
tentation de prescrire sans faire de
demander toujours plus et d'accorder
moins cette situation est
malheureusement devenue quotidienne
passer l'urgence le défi désormais celui
de la durée alors qu'aucun horizon de
fin de guerre ne se dessine et que
l'objectif légitime de libération de
l'ensemble du territoire souverain de
l'Ukraine semble encore lointain nous
devons maintenir la flamme de la
solidarité
plus encore dans le contexte de la
chondres offensive ukrainienne que j'ai
eu l'occasion d'évoquer une nouvelle
fois ce 26 juin avec le président de la
Rada dukraine monsieur Stéphane chouk
nous devons redoubler des forts pour que
le front tienne il faut que l'arrière ne
fléchisse pas tel est le sens profond de
l'aide que vous apportez et des
relations noires entre collectivités
françaises et ukrainiennes la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine ne peut non
plus être reporté à la fin de la guerre
naturellement l'impunité ne pourra
prévaloir il sera indispensable je tiens
à le souligner que l'agresseur continue
à l'effort de construction une fois la
paix établie mais dans l'intervalle
grâce à la quarantaine de jumelages
existantes entre les collectivités
territoriales de deux pays grâce à des
accords entre régions le champ des
possibles est vastes il vous appartient
de l'explorer davantage encore
mesdames et messieurs dans les
territoires bat le pouls d'une France
pragmatique et courageuse qui se prend
en main et du Ukraine qui résiste se
redresse et prépare sa reconstruction le
Sénat continuera d'être aux côtés des
territoires pour vous aider je vous
souhaite à toutes et tous des échanges
fructueux et je ne voudrais pas conclure
sans crier vive l'Ukraine et vive la
France
[Applaudissements]
très rapidement parce que l'essentiel ça
va être quand même les tables rondes
très rapidement à titre personnel je
tiens à vous dire je suis très heureux
de vous accueillir aujourd'hui au Sénat
pour cette ces deux tables rondes qui
viennent
heureux de remercier vivement Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur du crâne et son équipe je
souhaite aussi saluer la présence de
plusieurs représentants des
collectivités ukrainiennes parmi nous en
visioconférence je veux leur dire notre
soutien indéfectible et nous ferons en
sorte de leur céder assez rapidement la
parole
mais remerciements s'adressent également
à Monsieur l'Ambassadeur délégué pour
l'action extérieure des collectivités
territoriales qui s'exprimera tout à
l'heure
les collectivités terriales
territoriales françaises se sont
mobilisés dès la première heure pour
venir en aide à l'Ukraine agressée elles
ont dans un puissant élan de solidarité
accueille des réfugiés ou contribuer à
des dons humanitaires cet élan de
solidarité fait honneur à notre pays le
Sénat dont le rôle de représentant des
collectivités territoriales et
consacrées par notre Constitution et
particulièrement attaché à mettre en
valeur leurs initiatives dans le champ
de la coopération de cette décentralisée
le président Larcher vient de rappeler à
l'instant par le biais de son message
son attachement à cette coopération
cette guerre au porte de l'Europe est un
défi porté au droit international à la
souveraineté de l'Ukraine et à la
démocratie un défi auquel les
collectivités territoriales entendent
répondre ensemble en renforçant leur
lien c'est l'objet de nos échanges
d'aujourd'hui bien évidemment dans cette
guerre ce sont nos amis Ukrainiens qui
sont en première ligne et il s'agit pour
nos collectivités territoriales
françaises d'apporter une contribution
ajustée pragmatique en réponse aux
besoins de leurs homologues ukrainiennes
et ses besoins nous le savons sont
immenses dans le champ de la coopération
décentralisée beaucoup d'initiatives ont
été conduites et se poursuivent ce
soutien perdu évolue et se structure
mais comment rendre compte d'une
dynamique pouvant s'inscrire à la fois
dans un élan spontané et dans un cadre
plus structuré porté par des structures
gouvernementales ou associatives comment
donner de la cohérence à cet élan pour
mettre en valeur les initiatives de
chacun répondrait efficacement aux
besoins exprimés par nos partenaires
ukrainiens et développer les synergies
entre collectivités
apporter des éléments de réponse à ces
questions est aussi un moyen de
s'assurer de la résilience de ce
mouvement de soutien dans le temps tels
sont les objectifs de la première table
ronde de nombreuses collectivités ont
développé des partenariats historiques
avec des collectivités ukrainiennes sous
la forme notamment de jumelage depuis le
début de la crise ce mouvement
s'accélère c'est liens privilégiés ont
permis la mise en place d'actions de
soutien dès les premières heures du
conflit mais nos collectivités peuvent
aussi trouver auprès d'administration
comme la délégation à l'action
extérieure des collectivités
territoriales ou d'associations comme
l'Association des maires de France la
gestion des départements des régions de
France l'Association Française du
Conseil des communes et des régions
d'Europe ou cités Unifrance toute
représentée aujourd'hui des relais
indispensables et il en existe bien
d'autres notamment niveau local et on
pourrait naturellement pas toutes les
citer en mettant en place des
partenariats des outils spécifiques
d'aide tels que les fonds de soutien ces
organismes contribuent à structurer la
dynamique de solidarité la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui s'articulera ainsi en deux
temps la première session mettra en
avant combien le déclenchement du
conflit s'est traduit par n'importe en
développement des actions de coopération
entre collectivités françaises et
ukrainiennes le recueillerons à cette
fin le témoignage de plusieurs
collectivités représentant
d'associations j'aurai le plaisir de
modérer cette première session et mon
camarade
rappin modéra la deuxième et fera
peut-être la fin de la première session
parce que je malheureusement je serai
tenu d'aller présider la séance plénière
dans l'hémicycle
afin d'inscrire ce mouvement de soutien
dans le temps long la seconde session
portera sur l'engagement des
collectivités territoriales françaises
pour la reconstruction de l'Ukraine elle
sera animée par mon collègue
Jean-François Rapin qui préside la
commission des affaires européennes du
Sénat en effet diverses initiatives pour
accompagner la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine ont été lancées tant au niveau
national qu'au niveau européen et
international cette session
s'interrogera donc sur la place des
collectivités territoriales françaises
dans ce contexte je vais céder sans plus
tarder la parole à ma collègue madame
Nadia solo goub président du groupe
inter parlementaire d'amitié
franc-ukraine avec laquelle nous avons
organisé cet événement puis nous aurons
le plaisir d'écouter son Excellence
Monsieur vadimo melchenko ambassadeur
extraordinaire et pénis potentiaire du
crâne en France qui nous fait l'honneur
d'être parmi nous aujourd'hui ainsi que
bien sûr monsieur Jean-Paul Guillaumet
ambassadeur et délégué pour l'action
externe des collectivités territoriales
pour une introduction générale aux deux
sessions de cette table ronde je vous
remercie et je sais immédiatement la
parole un Nadia
[Applaudissements]
et bien sûr je veux remercier
chaleureusement les élus Ukrainiens
présents parmi nous cet après-midi en
visioconférence de la région et de la
ville de Tcherkassy des villes de
melitopol et de clemenshuk nous avons
également à distance des représentants
des villes d'irpines d'isium et de
chenil intéressé par ses échanges je
souhaite rendre hommage à votre courage
et à votre bravoure à votre combat
permanent pour que vive la démocratie
notamment au niveau local c'est une
source de respect et d'inspiration pour
nous tous
je salue également la présence de
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur délégué pour
l'action extérieure des collectivités
territoriales je suis très heureuse de
vous accueillir aujourd'hui au Sénat
dans le cadre de ces tables rondes
organisé à l'initiative de mon collègue
Roger caoutchi avec le concours du
groupe inter parlementaire d'amitié
franc suisse que j'ai l'honneur de
présider
si les liens avec nos homologues
Ukrainiens sont anciens ils se sont
renforcés dans le contexte si
particulier de la guerre dans le cadre
du groupe d'amitié France Ukraine avec
l'ensemble des sénateurs membres de ce
groupe ils sont plus d'une cinquantaine
à ce jour nous travaillons à enrichir et
consolider nos relations à tous les
niveaux et cela passe en particulier par
l'organisation de rencontres régulières
avec nos collègues Ukrainiens j'attache
beaucoup d'importance au développement
de nos relations personnelles afin que
notre amitié interparlementaire soit
véritablement incarné je crois pouvoir
affirmer aujourd'hui qu'elle repose sur
une profonde solidarité entre les
parlementaires de nos deux assemblées
nous sommes aussi pleinement engagés
pour faire vivre la coopération
décentralisée et affirmer notre soutien
aux élus locaux ukrainiens
nous avons par exemple accueilli au
Sénat le 23 novembre 2022 une délégation
de mer ukrainien venue témoigner de leur
quotidien d'élus de territoire en guerre
sous la menace permanente des
bombardements et des troupes russes ils
avaient été salués par une ovation
longue de plusieurs minutes dans
l'hémicycle en pleine séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement le
27 mars dernier mais quand elle Joël
guerriot Annick billon Michel Dagbert et
Joëlle gariomelham ont reçu ici une
autre délégation de quatre mers
Ukrainiens avec l'association
sandwichrainienne ants vous l'aurez
compris les relations avec les
collectivités locales me tiennent
particulièrement à coeur elles
permettent de créer des liens au sein de
nos territoires et de tisser de façon
très concrète un réseau de solidarité
sur lequel les Ukrainiens peuvent
s'appuyer et les collectivités
territoriales françaises souhaitent y
prendre une part active
en effet à l'échelle communale
départementale et régional tous les
niveaux de collectivité s'engagent pour
le soutien l'Ukraine dans ce conflit et
je me réjouis de les voir si bien
représenté aujourd'hui à son niveau le
groupe inter parlementaire d'amitié peut
servir de relais au projet des
collectivités et favoriser les mises en
réseau je voudrais aussi remercier
business France et la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie
franco-ukrainienne dont les
représentants sont parmi nous
aujourd'hui deux opérateurs dont
l'expertise se révèle indispensable pour
renforcer les synergies entre toutes les
parties prenantes partagez la
connaissance du marché ukrainien et
ouvrir le champ des possibles pour nos
acteurs publics et privés cette table
ronde s'annonce à non pas douter très
riche d'anciennement et de partage
d'expérience je vous remercie encore
l'ensemble des intervenants pour leur
disponibilité et les analyses qui nous
livreront sur ce sujet au combien
essentiels pour l'avenir du pays et de
l'Europe et je sais maintenant la parole
à son Excellence va dim Omelchenko
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur c'est à vous
[Applaudissements]
cher Monsieur le vice-président premier
livre précédent du Sénat
madame la présidente du groupe d'amitié
France Ukraine
je vois beaucoup de visages connus dans
cette salle beaucoup d'amis je salue
aussi le représentant de la communauté
ukrainienne en France Monsieur Coval je
salue également tous les participants
Ukrainiens qui participent à
visioconférence
imaginez à quel
quels sont aujourd'hui les conditions de
travail pour les maires Ukrainiens pour
les élus ukrainiens et je vous suis trop
reconnaissant que vous vous avez pu vous
joindre à nos aujourd'hui
je voudrais dire que à partir des
premiers jours de cette terrible guerre
c'est précisément les représentants des
communautés territoriales en France ont
été les premiers à répondre et à
proposer l'aide d'urgence
une semaine après
j'ai déjà été convié après le début de
la guerre j'ai été conviée à une réunion
du Sénat
j'ai pu témoigner ce qui se passe en
Ukraine
et ensuite une très grande vague de
soutien de solidarité a commencé à
monter venu des villes des localités des
des collectivités territoriales
et je voudrais dire que
tôt ou tard cette guerre sera terminée
maintenant nous sommes plus dans
l'urgence malheureusement et nous
parlons en termes
mais je voudrais dire également que
depuis quelques mois déjà à chaque
réunion des ambassadeurs qu'il
convoquent en visio
dans l'ordre du jour une question est un
après la première question de soutien
militaire et soutien politique le
deuxième question de l'ordre du jour
c'est la reconstruction de l'Ukraine
l'agenda de les constructions est déjà
bien inscrit dans les projets et c'est
très construction doit déjà être
réfléchie et préparé
le président de l'Ukraine a proposé le
plan le patronat
qui prévoit qui prévoit au collectivités
territoriales
de parrainer les collectivités
territoriales ukrainiennes et ainsi être
acteur de la reconstruction et donc ce
plan ukrainien la France a eu tout de
suite du répondant
et il y a des échanges qui se sont
installé
et installer dans la durée
par exemple le sénateur Larcher le
président Larcher et d'autres sénateurs
se sont rendus en Ukraine et
c'était très important et que pendant 7
ans très dur
les élus français les sénateurs ont
trouvé du temps pour venir et témoigner
votre soutien à l'Ukraine sur place
c'est un certain courage et
parce que c'est vraiment
les aléas de cette guerre et on peut
devenir victime collatérale de cette
guerre à tout moment donc c'est un
immense courage et je remercie beaucoup
à tous les citoyens français quel que
soit les postes qu'ils occupent et qui
qui se sont rendus en Ukraine pour la
soutenir et qui qui nous ont beaucoup
soutenu
en ce qui concerne la reconstruction
vous savez que la France a été
le premier pays et qui a organisé la
conférence de reconstruction il y a eu
deux forums le 13 le 13 décembre 2022 et
donc il y a eu un forum
qui a été accueilli par le ministère de
l'Économie des Finances à Bercy et
c'était un forum bilatéral qui était
consacrée donc à la question de
participation des entreprises françaises
dans la reconstruction de l'Ukraine et
le président français a participé tout
au long des travaux
à ce forum c'était un signe très fort un
engagement très fort personnel du
président français
lorsque il a adressé la salle où il y
avait des représentants en salle en
essentielle 700 entreprises françaises
et encore 10
000 autres entreprises françaises
participer en visio le président
français a délivrer ce message important
il faut pas attendre la fin de la guerre
commencer aujourd'hui votre engagement
votre engagement pour la reconstruction
allez en Ukraine voici ce que a dit le
président Macron
d'une grande somme importance c'est non
seulement une aide et une solidarité
mais je suis persuadée
que
je souhaite vraiment que dans ce nouveau
marché de le reconstruction les
compagnies françaises seront les
premières
qui vont qui vont arriver
parce que vous savez dans le monde
aujourd'hui des marchés instaurer c'est
rare d'avoir un tout nouveau marché
juste à côté alors que en Ukraine c'est
un territoire aussi beaucoup plus grand
que la France avec plusieurs millions
d'habitants qui créent plusieurs emplois
et qui a besoin de reconstruction tout
secteurs confondus et c'est pour ça je
j'appelle
régulièrement les sociétés françaises
les entreprises françaises de ne pas de
ne pas tarder de de devenir aujourd'hui
et s'engager aujourd'hui
et donc je reviens à cet événement du 13
décembre 2022 il y avait également le
volet international de la conférence de
la construction avec participation de
plusieurs pays à la nitive de du
président de la France
le président Macron donc a convoqué
cette grande conférence comment assister
la résilience ukrainienne comment
survivre à l'hiver vous savez que cet
hiver a été particulièrement difficile
parce que les missiles balistiques
russes ont spécialement visé les sites
d'infrastructures énergétiques
l'ennemi n'a pas caché ses intentions il
voulait plonger l'Ukraine dans le noir
et dans le froid afin que
donc et sans électricité
sans rien et pour leur faire peur pour
les terroriser et pour une fine et
peser sur leur moral pour ce que ce
moral se retourne et pour que
la population appelle à la capitulation
et à la sécession de territoires mais ce
calcul était 20
et
le forum auquel des résilience
auxquelles 54 pays ont participé et bien
cette initiative qui qui
nous a aidé à traverser l'hiver parce
que l'aide est arrivé très vite l'aide
en termes de générateur et tout ce qui
portait sur le l'aide l'assistance au
secteur énergétique et les dérivés très
efficacement et très rapidement et c'est
ça qui nous a aidé pour traverser cet
hiver
aujourd'hui nous avons déjà
les premiers calculs les estimations il
y a plus de
80.000 sites
qui ont été détruits par cette guerre
c'est on parle évidemment des
territoires déjà libérés on ne peut pas
encore faire de bilan sur les
territoires
occupés
lorsque les territoires est libéré
découper c'est un territoire qui qui est
en ruine c'est un champ de ruines il
faut tout reconstruire
les chaînes françaises couvrent en
continu cette actualité avec les images
de désolation et les Français disent que
c'est leur rappelle la Première Guerre
mondiale malheureusement
[Musique]
et donc nous avons un vaste chantier un
vaste chantier de reconstruction
et nous avons déjà
beaucoup de représentants de différentes
échelles
communales départementales régionales
qui sont qui se rendent sur place et des
liens très très sérieux sont tissés
entre les collectivités par exemple une
des premières régions qui a répondu
c'était l'Île-de-France et les régions
Île-de-France a pris donc jumelage avec
la région de clip et de tchernikive la
région Grand Est fait le patronage sur
la région de Cardiff la région Provence
Alpes-Maritimes la région d'Odessa et
actuellement il y a un partenaire
institutionnalisé entre Normandie
Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui cherche donc
des partenaires
le président a dit a déjà cité le nombre
des jumelages mais je pense que c'est
pas un nombre définitif il y a beaucoup
plus de perspectives en vue parce que
des nouveaux projets de jumelage
naissent tous les jours et nous espérons
que
cette coopération va se poursuivre
au-delà de la fin de cette guerre va
être vraiment durable
par exemple il y a quelques jours au
début de mois de juillet à
Issy-les-Moulineaux il y avait un
congrès très important jumelage Europe
et jumelage et j'ai été très très émue
très touché
par les témoignages des
mères craignant il y avait le la vice
Mer de la ville de corosteg correspond
qui est dans la région de tchernie Yves
qui est venu témoigner à ce forum
c'était vous savez qu'on restait une
c'est tout près de la ligne de front
dans les premières semaines domaine de
la guerre cette ville a été sous des
feux très intenses d'artillerie et il y
avait un petit garçon né de 10 ans qui
qui a perdu les deux jambes dans cette
dent qui était touchés par le bus et a
perdu deux jambes et les réseaux sociaux
ont capté cette image et du récit de ce
garçon et bien tout de suite le
maire de la ville de Bourges a appelé
le vice-mère de corestenne et a dit que
il a vu ce garçon né et il a voulu il a
tout de suite tendu la main et a proposé
de d'établir donc des contacts entre les
villes corossten et Bourges et de de
fournir l'aide humanitaire et c'est
aujourd'hui cette cette coopération et
c'était de toujours très très active
et donc il y avait eu beaucoup de
manifestations spontanées il y a
beaucoup de cas comme ça
et c'est vrai que c'est très important
d'avoir un plan
un plan de gel
et il y a une société française et gise
d'assaut et encore deux autres sociétés
mais je ne peux pas encore
citer d'autres noms mais c'est société
propa actuellement font
donc grâce aux images satellites et les
modèles il font donc
toute la carte
ukrainienne de l'Ukraine détruite par la
guerre
parce que ils ont des images des villes
d'avant et ils font maintenant
le jumeau comme ça virtuel des villes et
la carte de destruction
il y a aussi une société néo-éco vous
savez
nous avons une ville qui a joué un rôle
très important dans cette guerre a dit
km de cuivre la ville de rostomel la
ville où les troubles
sont été parachutés et les troupes
d'élite et ce commando devait monter et
pour prendre la ville de Kiev et cette
ville livrée une résistance très
farouche donc elle a souffert la ville
de rostomel a souffert énormément des
combats qui se sont déroulés dans la
ville même et c'est la société Neo et
qui est qui a utilisé la technologie
innovantes ils ont déjà reconstruit 25
logements 25 immeubles dans la ville et
leur technologie innovante est
absolument exemplaire ils ont à partir
des matériaux de destruction ils ont ils
ont un logiciel qui les et qui les
réutilise et donc voilà c'est c'est une
technologie très innovante et grâce à
cette technologie déjà 25 immeubles ont
été reconstruits et c'est vraiment très
bien que l'avenir nous guide les
technologies n'avantes c'est ça qui nous
distingue de notre ennemi qui lui est
tourné juste vers le passé et notre
projet c'est non seulement
reconstruire l'Ukraine mais c'est de
construire une Ukraine qui sera un pays
le plus attractif le plus ouvert vers le
monde et l'Ukraine doit être
reconstruite grâce aux technologies
innovantes
c'est pour ça nous proposons
nous proposons à toutes les sociétés
françaises et aussi tous les sociétés
internationales
de faire de pousser leurs meilleures
technologies utilisées l'Ukraine comme
un cas d'école pour pour déployer les
technologies les plus innovantes
et pour conclure
je voudrais vous dire que nous
oppressions énormément le soutien de la
France
juste pour que vous ayez une idée à quel
point elle a le rôle de la France le
leadership de la France est important de
la dans le monde nous avons besoin de
l'aide de soutien militaire de soutien
politique et de soutien humanitaire de
la part de la France
on entend ici en France beaucoup de
critiques à l'égard du gouvernement
mais c'est normal pour un pays
démocratique d'entendre les critiques en
Ukraine c'est pareil
je voudrais vraiment souligner que
aujourd'hui la France a un très une très
grande influence dans le monde une très
grande influence toute résolution et qui
aujourd'hui adopté au Conseil et à l'ONU
et il est impossible sans la France elle
est souvent portée par la France
toutes les décisions importantes de la
communauté internationale ils ont été
souvent initié sous le leadership de la
France en France
en Europe la France a le leadership
c'est le pays qui est influenceur et
décideur
par exemple
la crise énergétique
a été surmontée grâce à cette Lucie car
ce rôle de la France
et donc nous remercions beaucoup la
France pour cette proposition proactive
la France
nous aide également énormément sur le
plan de livraison
d'armement et du matériel militaire la
France a été un des premiers pays qui a
commencé à nous livrer les armes au
standard de l'OTAN et c'était très
important pour nous et aujourd'hui
cette aide est inscrite est inscrite
dans la durée
et le président français et mélanise ça
va être étrangère madame Colonna à
plusieurs fois réitérer le message que
la France sera aux côtés de l'Ukraine
jusqu'à la victoire
et c'est très important et
troisième volet le volet humanitaire je
ne serai pas dire
c'est souvent merci et remercier assez
la France pour cette aide humanitaire
parce que c'était elle est vraiment
exemplaire la solidarité des Français
est exemplaire à tous les niveaux à
niveau des petites et grandes villes au
niveau des collectivités
région
c'est l'Ukraine
continue de se battre continue de
résister et quand les soldats sur le
front qui ont par moment la connexion et
qui peuvent voir les nouvelles du monde
ça renforce tellement leur moral de
savoir que la France est à leur côté le
monde est à leur côté et nous serons
éternellement reconnaissants au peuple
français à la nation française pour
cette aide
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le Premier vice-président du
Sénat madame la présidente du groupe
d'amitié mesdames et messieurs en vos
titres et qualités le protocole était en
observé je voudrais vous dire combien je
suis heureux de prendre la parole
aujourd'hui mais surtout de pouvoir
participer de pouvoir écouter tout ce
qui va se dire cet après-midi pour venir
en aide à nos amis
Ukrainiens c'est naturellement pour moi
un honneur de représenter le ministère
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
j'essaye de le faire le mieux possible
depuis quelques 30 ans mais je ne
voudrais pas
succomber à cette tentation de prescrire
sans faire que relevait dans son adresse
le président du Sénat donc je vais
plutôt me contenter de rappeler quelques
idées importantes sur cette coopération
décentralisée entre la France et
l'Ukraine avant bien évidemment de vous
écouter d'écouter des suggestions qui
j'espère vont émerger des deux tables
rondes la première chose a déjà été dit
mais je pense qu'il est important que le
ministère de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères le sunning c'est
l'effort considérable qui a été accompli
par les collectivités territoriales
françaises depuis le début de
l'agression contre l'Ukraine plus de
1800 collectivités territoriales
françaises ont ainsi abondé le fasecco
Fondaction extérieure des collectivités
territoriales à hauteur de plus de 11
millions d'euros
et ce fond de concours comme vous le
savez est géré par le centre de crise et
de soutien en lien avec la délégation
dont j'assume la responsabilité il
permet aux collectivités territoriales
qui le désirent d'apporter une aide
d'urgence efficace aux victimes de crise
humanitaire nous l'avons bien vu il
répondait à un besoin des collectivités
françaises en termes de redevabilité en
termes de facilité d'acheminement de
cette aide même si bien évidemment se
fasse écho n'a pas vocation à éliminer
toute autre forme de coopération en
faveur de nos amis Ukrainiens nous avons
vu par exemple combien il était
important
de donner un second souffle assez liés
de jumelage qu'il y avait déjà entre
collectivités françaises et
collectivités ukrainienne ou d'utiliser
d'autres liens comme ceux qui unissent
les collectivités françaises et les
collectivités polonaises ou
roumaine
je voudrais
vous dire également combien depuis le
déclenchement de cette agression ce sont
multipliées les rencontres les
événements conjoints entre représentants
de collectivités françaises et
ukrainiennes et je voudrais saluer le
travail accompli par mes collègues en
poste à Kief mais également le réseau
des conseillers diplomatiques auprès des
préfets de région qui s'assurent que les
informations pertinentes parviennent
auprès des élus dans les territoires
je me dois aussi de saluer le rôle
exemplaire de région de France des
départements de France de l'Association
des maires de France et des autres
associations de collectivités
territoriales dans la diffusion de cette
information pour que nous puissions
toujours répondre au plus vite et au
mieux aux besoins des collectivités
ukrainiennes
alors se pose aujourd'hui pour nous
plusieurs défis le premier et ce n'est
pas j'irai pour l'histoire que je m'en
préoccupe c'est de dresser
à une cartographie de faire une
cartographie de dresser un une liste
aussi précise que possible des
initiatives prises par les collectivités
territoriales et c'est un travail
éminemment difficile puisque tout à fait
naturellement c'est
de la part des collectivités
territoriales que naissent c'est
initiatives en faveur des collectivités
ukrainiennes et il n'est pas nécessaire
ce sera vraiment je crois tout à fait
contraire à l'esprit de la coopération
des centralisée qu'elle soit soumise à
quelques accords préalables de je ne
sais quelle représentant de l'État la
difficulté c'est que aujourd'hui nous
devons éviter les nous organiser au
mieux
pour être plus efficace et on l'a vu au
tout départ lorsque c'était long de
solidarité des Français c'est manifester
il y avait parfois peut-être plus de
Gênes que d'aide qui était apportée aux
collectivités françaises
ukrainienne pardon je voudrais assister
sur deux outils dont nous disposons pour
procéder à ce recensement tout d'abord
l'Atlas français de la Coopération
Décentralisée qui est disponible sur le
site de la Commission nationale de la
coopération décentralisée et également
une fois par an la déclaration d'aide
publique au développement que renseigne
les collectivités territoriales qui donc
ont effectué des dépenses éligibles à
l'aide publique au développement
je voudrais souligner l'importance de la
Commission nationale de la coopération
décentralisée dans ce travail elle a
sous l'impulsion de son vice-président
Monsieur Patrick Molinoz vice-président
non seulement de la Commission nationale
de la coopération décentralisée mais
également du conseil régional de
Bourgogne Franche-Comté elle a lancé un
groupe de travail
Ukraine et ce groupe de travail qui
s'est réuni jusqu'à présent une fois
mais devrait se réunir dès la rentrée de
septembre aura pour mission non
seulement de recenser ce qui se fait
déjà mais de dégager des bonnes
pratiques pour que des collectivités
françaises qui ont envie de venir en
aide à des collectivités territoriales
ukrainiennes puissent s'inspirer
d'exemples qui marchent d'exemples qui
réussissent même si bien évidemment la
situation est différente d'une
collectivité à l'autre
participe à ce groupe
les associations de collectivités
territoriales représentées à la CNCD et
lors de la première séance nous avons eu
l'occasion d'échanger avec Pierre
heillebron l'envoyé spécial du Président
de la République pour la reconstruction
de l'Ukraine au cours de cette session a
émerger l'idée d'organiser peut-être au
1er semestre
2024 une rencontre entre collectivités
territoriales françaises et
collectivités
ukrainiennes je voudrais à ce propos
saluer
une fois encore non seulement les
organisateurs de de la réunion
d'aujourd'hui mais le rôle du Sénat
depuis le déclenchement de cette
agression de l'Ukraine le Sénat fidèle à
sa tradition de chambre des territoires
valorise l'action extérieure des
collectivités territoriales
un moment où elle est parfois remise en
cause ce qui peut se comprendre vu de
contexte économique et politique
difficile de notre pays mais toujours
aussi indispensable cette action
extérieure alors outre des filles que je
vois c'est très franchement maintenir
cet élan de solidarité je dois vous dire
après les très bons chiffres de 2022 le
fasecco en 2023 ne rencontrent pas le
même succès c'est peut-être aussi un bon
signe puisque comme la très bien
expliqué le président de la République
nous sommes passés de la phase d'urgence
à la phase de résilience et comme nous y
invite l'ambassadeur du crâne il faut
aujourd'hui
penser être tendu vers la phase de
reconstruction donc bien évidemment
l'action de solidarité l'action
humanitaire d'urgence qui accomplissent
directement ou indire ctement des
collectivités territoriales avec très
souvent un appui des organisations de
solidarité internationale reste tout à
fait pertinent mais nous sommes déjà
maintenant en train de réfléchir à la
prière et la reconstruction alors
c'est là que l'on voit un troisième défi
intervenir aujourd'hui dans un pays qui
est en guerre et je ne reviendrai pas
sur les propos extrêmement juste et
précis de l'ambassadeur du crâne mais
vous savez très bien quand vous suivez
l'actualité que le conflit n'est pas
limité à une partie du territoire et ça
fait d'ailleurs totalement parti je
crois de la stratégie de l'agresseur que
intervalle régulier
choisir des cibles civiles y compris
dans toutes les parties du territoire
pour créer la plus grande instabilité
possible mais il faut tout de même et on
l'a vu ça a été possible plusieurs
missions de présidents de conseil
régionaux particuliers ou d'élus
métropolitains début départementaux ce
sont rendus en Ukraine parce qu'il est
déjà possible
d'aller voir sur le terrain ce qui sera
nécessaire de faire au moment de la
reconstruction je voudrais
rappeler encore une fois la grande
dispositive d'imbilité du ministère de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères nous
avons des outils classiques les
principaux intervenants dans le domaine
de la l'action extérieure des
collectivités territoriales connaissent
bien essentiellement des appels à
projets dans le cas de l'Ukraine nous
sommes plus que jamais
disposés à essayer de faire preuve de
flexibilité alors ça peut paraître un
peu contradictoire dans la bouche d'un
fonctionnaire mais vu l'urgence de la
situation
Ukraine et de et la particularité de
cette situation nous sommes tout à fait
prêts à étudier avec des collectivités
individuellement ou avec des
associations de collectivités
territoriales comment mettre en place
des outils pour mieux appuyer appuyer
davantage l'action des collectivités
territoriales à destination de l'Ukraine
je voudrais à titre d'exemple salués
l'initiative de l'afccrre qui a réussi
si je puis dire à marier à partir de
l'exemple émouvant rappelé par
l'ambassadeur du crâne les villes de
Bourges mais également celle de La
Rochelle et celle de Sceaux ce sont
trois petits exemples peut-être mais
j'espère que ce sont trois premiers
exemples d'une vague de partenariat pas
forcément des jumelages si je puis dire
à l'ancienne qui ont fait leur preuve je
suis un produit de la réconciliation
franco-allemande en grande partie grâce
à ces jumelages des territoires
mais je crois que autour de projets très
concrets de partenariats des
collectivités territoriales quel que
soit leur taille quel que soit leur
typologie depuis une petite commune et
plus grande métropoles les conseils
départementaux les conseils régionaux
bien sûr toutes les collectivités
territoriales françaises peuvent trouver
un projet de partenariat avec le crâne
et je voudrais donc en particulier à
destination des associations de
collectivités territoriales françaises
représentée ici aujourd'hui leur dire
combien nous aimerions vous aider à
gérer
davantage de collectivités territoriales
françaises et grainienne non pas
seulement pour la symbolique du geste et
la symbolique s'accompte dans un conflit
armé mais pour la réalité de tous ces
projets qui pourront ensuite germer une
fois la paix retrouvée et je l'espère
donc très très prochainement encore une
fois je ne voudrais pas être trop long
puisque je suis surtout venu pour
vous écouter
et je vous remercie infiniment je
félicite encore une fois le Sénat pour
cette très très belle initiative qui
nous réunit aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite et sans tarder
attaquer la première table ronde je
demande s'ils veulent bien
à Madame Dominique Delmas
monsieur Thibault Guignard
madame Berthol s'ils sont là les trois
de bien vouloir me venir vers moi et à
Monsieur François richesse de bien
vouloir prendre la parole au nom de la
Fédération nationale de la protection
civile
merci Monsieur vice-président
dans le cadre de ce discours introductif
pour cette table ronde vous avez
souhaité que j'intervienne par rapport à
cette forme véritable et lange
générosité qu'on a pu assouvir si on
peut dire au travers de ce partenariat
qui a été mené entre la protection
civile notre fédération et puis
l'ensemble des collectivités que ce soit
la scission des maires de France mais
aussi l'ensemble des collectivités
région départements et puis bien sûr
Vincent toutes les collectivités vous
permettrez de revenir en quelques mots
sur le fondement de mai même de la
protection civile de ces bénévoles de
ces 32000 bénévoles c'est d'être présent
auprès des populations
lors de pour venir en aide auprès des
progressions civiles en temps de paix
comme en temps de crise ou en termes de
guerre donc il était tout naturel le 24
février dernier
lors de du début de la guerre que les
bénévoles retroussent leurs manches et
surtout s'engagent c'était ça le live
motif de l'ensemble des bénévoles dès le
24 février c'est qu'est-ce que l'on a
les faire quelle allait être notre rôle
et donc il était tout naturel de se
retourner vers notre partenaire l'AMF ce
sont des maires de France et je salue
Thibault guinner ici présent avec qui on
a longuement travaillé durant durant
l'année écoulée il est dans été donc
tout naturel de avec notre partenaire
historique qui est la MF de monter
ensemble une sorte de d'ingénierie de
projet pour voir comment ensemble
élu et bénévole nous pouvions répondre
aux besoins des administrés et des
Français des concitoyens
et au final tout allait très très vite
très très vite le premier mars avec le
président Isnard on décide
lors d'une vision
peut-être dans la main si on peut dire
si on peut dire et on décide ensemble de
de mettre en place certaines génériques
projets avec ce but que tout Français
puisse être acteur de cette générosité
et venir en aide du peuple ukrainien
le premier convoi quitter
Strasbourg
notre premier convoi partir et dès cette
date là mais c'est un ensemble de
convois près de 500 véhicules 500 semi
remorque 5 trains humanitaires et là
c'était clairement un sacré challenge on
a mis en place un train humanitaire on
est parti de zéro et je sais que votre
expérience chère Vadim vous avez pu voir
l'ensemble de nos entrepôts dont un à
Villeneuve-Saint-Georges c'était
le premier kilomètre était réalisé quand
je dis le premier kilomètre était
réalisé grâce à l'élan des collectivités
et les 5000 points de collecte qui avait
pu être mis en oeuvre au plus près des
populations on arrivait en trois quatre
semaines à collecter plus de 8000 tonnes
de matériel 8000 tonnes qui ont été à
l'issue distribués de façon progressive
de façon ciblée sur le territoire
ukrainien grâce à trois logistiques
basées en Pologne en Slovaquie et en
Roumanie ce qui nous permettait d'avoir
la meilleure desserte possible de
l'ensemble du territoire ukrainien et
aussi d'adapter la réponse aux besoins
très ciblé donc je voulais vraiment
revenir sur sur ces points là c'est ce
qui a été de notre force des bénévoles
et aussi des
collectivités c'est notre proximité
c'est la proximité vis-à-vis des de nos
concitoyens cette capacité que l'on a à
être aussi très pragmatique parce que
l'élu que j'appelle sous bien souvent le
praticien de la République c'est quand
même il a cette capacité comme le
bénévole de protection civile à
s'adapter à la situation il a trouvé en
quelques instants la réponse
proportionnelle aux besoins et donc je
voulais vraiment revenir sur ce sur ces
chiffres 8000 tonnes de matériel 15000
palettes 500 véhicules 500 semi-remorque
pardon deux bateaux parce qu'on a aussi
participé cet élan de joué avec le MAE
je parle toujours en ancien en ancien
franc mais c'est un me à eux
ainsi que deux avions qui ont permis à
la fois de la cheminée du matériel et de
permettre à des à des déplacer à des
Ukrainiens déplacés de venir sur le
territoire national
je pense que notre force
elle a été sur cette capacité à
collecter au plus près
être réactif
avoir une très bonne traçabilité des
dons pour pouvoir rendre compte et aussi
s'inscrire dans la durée j'insiste sur
ce sur ce point inscrire dans la durée
on a collecté du premier au dernier
kilomètre bien entendu
on a répondu à ce besoin du peuple
crânien mais je pense aussi que grâce à
cette
à cette cette action commune on a permis
à tout citoyen français d'être un peu
acteur de cette malheureuse crise et de
pouvoir
avec le
selon les moyens de chacun répondre à
cette élan générosité qui était vous en
souvenez sur les premières semaines
c'est il y avait un élan tel qui fallait
arriver à le canaliser et surtout
arriver à cibler la réponse
en temps parallèle je n'oublie pas je
n'oublie pas quand on en parallèle les
bénévoles ont été aussi une nouvelle
fois engagés avec les avec les
collectivités dans un grand nombre de
points sur le territoire national pour
accueillir monsieur l'Ambassadeur vos
concitoyens les accueillir les
populations déplacées sur les deux trois
premiers mois là une nouvelle fois on a
relevé ce défi qui est plus notre cas
dans notre corps de métier cette
capacité d'accueillir des gens qui sont
déplacés on le fait de façon régulière
lors de l'incendie ou autre sur le
territoire national je n'oublie pas par
exemple les feux de forêt de la Gironde
l'année dernière ou la protection civile
aux côtés des pouvoirs publics étaient
très engagés pour accueillir des des nos
concitoyens qui étaient
déplacé
au travers des différents feux de forêts
donc on a on a mené ces deux actions de
front j'oublie pas le centre du Bourget
sans du Bourget c'est devais accueillir
2000 personnes et on nous a demandé de
le monter en 48 heures
au bout de la 24e heure on était capable
d'accueillir 600 personnes à l'instant T
et ça c'est bien la force de la
protection civile une nouvelle fois avec
les collectivités tout ça c'est ça a été
vraiment je pense la force de ce de
cette mission elle a été résidée dans
notre capset pragmatique être tout
simplement agile
voilà ce que je pouvais dire sur cette
première phase bien sûr l'action a
continué parce que c'était bien une de
la volonté commune avec l'ensemble des
collectivités puis avec l'AMF
courant octobre novembre de l'année de
l'année passée on a souhaité continuer
on a Souter rester dans l'action et
comme vous l'avez dit Monsieur
ambassadeur le froid venant
[Musique]
les actions sont recentrées sur des
actions beaucoup plus ciblées beaucoup
plus ciblées au travers de des groupes
électrogènes et de stations de chauffage
et il a une nouvelle fois de façon très
très efficace avec la somme des mères de
France on a mis en place
une action assez simple qui avait pour
but de créer en même temps que d'envoyer
des groupes électrogènes et des stations
de chauffage de pouvoir créer ce premier
jumelage dont vous avez parlé se
rapprochement des collectivités
françaises avec les collectivités
ukrainiennes et là on a monté ce petit
générique assez simple autour de
finalement un groupe électrogène un
jumelage en résumé
ce qui était quelque chose d'assez
efficace qui continue qui continue on
est encore dans cette phase là même si
le besoin est un peu moins conséquent on
en parlait avec Monsieur ambassadeur
mais on a continué ses actions et puis
d'autres actions avec les collectivités
je n'oublie pas les alors moi j'appelle
ça les camions poubelles de la ville de
Paris mais il y a eu une belle action
menée des camions poubelles qui ont été
envoyés sur les zones de front puis des
partenariats aussi avec des acteurs
privés ou semi-publique ou Syndicat des
énergies renouvelables ou près de 800
poêles à Blois et ont été envoyés la
région Île-de-France avec laquelle on a
pu envoyer quatre stations de chauffage
pour chauffer des hôpitaux là on était
sur un segment beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus élevé et puis encore
une nouvelle fois lors de lors du lors
de la rupture du barrage
on a continué l'action donc c'est encore
plus récent au travers avec des nos
partenaires institutionnels mais aussi
privés la Fondation Air France avec
l'envoi de de différents matériels et
pour cette rentrée pour la rentrée
scolaire
en lien avec la région Île-de-France
c'est une volonté de la région
Île-de-France et là on va participer à
cet effort
vous avez parlé de reconstruction
on s'y engage à notre à notre mesure
[Musique]
au travers de projets locaux et
l'ambition qui est plus qu'une ambition
de la protection civile c'est le
lancement à mettre vine d'un projet de
télémédecine donc sur une sur un secteur
qui est un peu moins soumis aux attaques
mais qui a pour but de tester cette
cette thématique sur une zone de guerre
et ainsi de répondre à un besoin de du
peuple ukrainien qui a sur des secteurs
comme nous en France des difficultés à
avoir un maillage médical fort et en
plus de ça au vu de la guerre c'est
encore plus compliqué donc lancement de
la thématique notre expertise autour de
la formation Ogès sur le premier secours
avec le mystère de l'éducation nationale
ukrainien et puis comme je le dis bien
souvent monsieur le moi ça dehors cette
volonté de transmettre notre expertise
dans le cas d'une protection
cilukrainienne qui aurait pour but qui a
pour but de mettre le citoyen acteur de
sa sécurité mais je pense que
malheureusement le peuple le peuple
ukrainien en a pleinement conscience et
je sais très bien que les Ukrainiens
sont naturellement acteurs de leur
sécurité au travers de ce terrible
conflit pour terminer
je pense que ce qu'on peut retenir de ce
de cette action commune entre
collectivités et membres du bénévolat ce
qui a été notre force pour porter cette
réponse alors elle est bien sûr
perfectible à toutes et perfectible
c'est la force de notre maillage
territorial le maillage territorial de
la protection civile et bien sûr des
collectivités et surtout et surtout
j'insiste sur ce point le prime
pragmatisme de terrain tout simplement
la capacité qu'on les élus et les
bénévoles a toujours trouvé un moyen
pour mener à bien leur mission voilà ce
que je voulais vous
transmettre au travers de ce propos
introductifs et je vous remercie
monsieur le Président je vais céder
désormais la parole représentant de la
région de tcherkasi son président
Monsieur un atelier petgorni son premier
vice-président monsieur romain souchenko
ainsi que Madame marina arkava vismère
de la ville de Tcherkassy qui nous font
l'honneur de leur présence en
visioconférence si cela à l'amabilité de
fonctionner
la liaison est parfaite
la connexion est parfaite
la connexion est très bonne on vous
entend
est-ce que vous nous entendez est-ce que
vous est-ce que vous nous entendez et
vous nous entendez bien
de la région de
livrer votre témoignage devant
l'Assemblée ici réuni au Sénat français
en vous remerciant bien entendu d'avoir
accepté cette visioconférence je vous
souhaite de la parole monsieur pitgorny
[Musique]
nous écoutons monsieur le Président
malheureusement
et monsieur pedigorny a dû se
reconnecter enfin il a dû relancer la
connexion et donc je prends la parole à
sa place
cher monsieur le Président de Sénat
monsieur les ambassadeurs mais se
laisser les sénateurs tous les
participants de cette honorable
assemblée
c'est une grande honneur
de participer dans ce dans cette
conférence dans cette table ronde nous
vous remercions beaucoup pour cette
invitation nous représentons ici la
région de tcherkassé la région qui est
située au centre de l'Ukraine voilà
j'ai animé lettres cette transition mais
je passe la parole à président à la
présidente monsieur le Président au pays
de Gournay
[Musique]
de cette région
nous vous remercions beaucoup pour votre
invitation
et nous souhaitions
remercier très chaleureusement le peuple
français pour son soutien
au peuple crânien à cette époque
terrible à cette épreuve terrible que
nous vivons tout d'abord grand merci
pour la livraison des armes c'était très
important pour nous pour continuer notre
combat armé merci pour le soutien
humanitaire merci pour
pour aussi tellement important pour nous
pour les personnes ici qui ont perdu
leurs proches qui ont perdu leur maison
et nous sommes persuadés que ce genre de
rencontre
vous permettra de créer de nouveaux
liens entre les collectivités parce que
nous avons ici un grand potentiel
potentiel pour l'échange d'expérience
pour la pour les pour la coopération
surtout nous comptons sur vous pour
reconstruire notre pays et surmonter les
épreuves de liées à la guerre
officiellement selon les estimations que
nous avons les sombres statistiques 80
.000 sites déjà ravagés détruit par
cette guerre
et nous serons très reconnaissants dès
lors à la France de d'être à notre côté
dans ce chantier de reconstruction
et nous espérons qu'il y aura beaucoup
de projets très concrets qui qui vont
qui vont être
décider et mis en oeuvre et qui vont
témoigner une fois de plus de la force
de ration de l'amitié entre la France et
l'Ukraine maintenant je passe la parole
au mon premier vice-président monsieur
romane sushiko vous savez monsieur
souchinko a longtemps vécu en France il
y a tout un réseau de l'amitié de
solidarité en France sur lequel il s'est
appuyé et c'est lui maintenant qui œuvre
énormément pour renforcer la coopération
bilatérale entre la France Ukraine
monsieur sushinko je vous passe la
parole
merci beaucoup monsieur président
pour rebondir
par le président de région je voudrais
vraiment souligner que la région de
Tcherkassy c'est un vraiment un place de
résistance une place arrière qui est au
centre de pays mais qui est une place
très importante pour que le pays puisse
continuer la résistance
cette région au centre de l'Ukraine est
une importance stratégique parce que
tous les corridors les axes de transport
passent les par cette par cette région
les autoroutes les c'est un infirmière
donc c'est aussi une région très
agricole
50% des sols que nous avons dans cette
région ce sont les seuls
et le l'industrie agroalimentaire se
développe beaucoup et appuyer sur
l'agriculture et c'est un atout pour
nous pour soutenir notre sécurité
alimentaire pour soutenir le front pour
nous avons aussi malgré la guerre puis
participer à la solidarité
alimentaire dans le monde
des premiers jours de la de cette guerre
la région de serres-casi est devenue la
région de transit pour les personnes
déplacées internes
c'était surtout les femmes et enfants
qui traversaient notre région et qui
s'est journée et quelques temps à
tcherkasi
par exemple 50000 de personnes
ont transité par la ville de Tcherkassy
et pendant qu'ils étaient dans la ville
elle dit toutes les conditions
nécessaires ont été créées pour les
hébergers pour les enfants pour être
accueillis dans les écoles
la région de turcassé garde un lien
économique très fort avec la France un
quart
de avoir la guerre avant la guerre un
quart de chiffres d'affaires que avait
la région de tcherkozy
c'était avec la France
les principaux articles d'exportation
c'était surtout les céréales et les
tuyaux les engins
il est aussi les les engrais
la région de cercle classique est
également célèbre pour la construction
pour le section pour son secteur de
construction de machines et pour son
secteur de
des pharmaceutiques
dans notre région il y a aussi un très
grand fort potentiel universitaire
étudiant 200 000 étudiants
que notre compte notre région et ce
serait très important de promouvoir la
mobilité entre les étudiants
et pour que les futurs personnes par
professionnel formé jeunes
professionnels puissent nous aider à
construire le pays
je propose
maintenant à tous les partenaires
potentiels en France et grâce à la
médiation de l'ambassade de France de
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur en particulier
nous avons
identifier et et
le partenaire donc
c'était encore avant la guerre nous
avons
identifié donc le partenaire la ville de
Montpellier pour crever pour créer un
jumelage et aussi la région
Occitanie la guerre a malheureusement
interrompu nos contacts actifs mais mais
maintenant nous avons cette volonté de
rétablir tout ce que tout ce que je me
suis mis en rapport avec Monsieur
Casabon
avec qui j'étais en lien avant et je
compte sur votre appui institutionnel
monsieur les sénateurs pour motiver ses
collectivités pour que nous puissions
signer les aides mémoires et ensuite
pour suivre une coopération structurée
je voudrais aussi maintenant passer la
parole à la vie se mère de la ville de
tcherkassim Madame Marina arkava qui va
parler des projets concrets
mais mes hommages
mes hommages à tous les participants
avec un grand respect pour la France et
le peuple français avec une immense
reconnaissance pour votre aide je
voudrais vous informer que nous avons
fait un aide-mémoire avec la Fondation
Priam qui aide
aux personnes déplacées internes et
c'était très précieuse pour tous les
déplacer internes qui sont restés dans
notre ville dans la ville de tchercassé
moi je dans la ville et je suis
responsable de la connexion qui s'est
interrompue
moi je veux bien écouter en attendant
que l'Ukraine revienne vers nous je vais
passer la parole immédiatement à Madame
Dominique Delmas qui m'excusera si
l'Ukraine revient de l'interrompre et je
passe donc la parole de Madame Dominique
Delmas conseillère départemental du
conseil départemental du département de
la Lozère membre de la commission des
solidarités humaines et lui référente
solidarité
Ukraine vous avez la parole madame la
conseillère merci
mesdames et messieurs en vous gras de
qualité bonjour donc tout d'abord
permettez-moi de vous remercier pour
cette invitation à participer à cette
table ronde en effet cela au nord la
Lozère et ses habitants et c'est une
reconnaissance de notre engagement et de
notre solidarité envers le peuple
ukrainien
la Lozère et le département le moins
peuplé de France 76000 habitants et du
coup le Conseil départemental le plus
petit de France dans sa strat et avec le
budget correspondant
pour autant cela n'empêche pas
d'anticiper les difficultés et de
prendre des initiatives en effet notre
taille nous impose d'être innovants
audacieux et solidaire entre nous
si la Lozère semble pour beaucoup un
territoire lointain cela ne l'empêche
pas de s'intéresser au monde qui
l'entoure et la crise du crâne a été le
parfait exemple dont je vous apporte
donc le témoignage de notre collectivité
territoriale qui est devenu actrice dans
ce conflit et qui démontre une nouvelle
fois que l'échelons départementales
reste primordial
donc dès le vendredi 25 février 2022 au
lendemain de l'invasion russe madame
Sophie Pentel présidente du conseil
départemental a pris la tâche auprès de
Monsieur Vadim au melchenko
pour lui faire ambassadeur du crâne à
Paris afin de lui faire part de la
pleine mobilisation de la Lozère dans
l'accueil des futurs réfugiés FIA les
bombardements avec les services de votre
ambassade nous avons pu établir une
liste des premiers besoins en direction
des réfugiés en vue de mettre en place
un premier convoi humanitaire
donc nous avons pour cela établi un lien
direct avec l'association Caritas
Pologne les franges les Français de
l'étranger en Pologne dont le président
Baptiste Rougerie a des attaches en
Lozère l'ambassade de France ainsi que
les autorités locales pour sécuriser le
convoi jusqu'à la frontière polono
ukrainienne et s'assurer de la bonne
distribution des denrées vêtements et
matériel médical
le Conseil départemental en parallèle a
voté une enveloppe exceptionnelle de 50
000 euros pour opération solidarité
Ukraine afin de financer les actions à
venir
un appel à la solidarité était donc
lancé par le département sur les réseaux
sociaux auprès des particuliers et des
entreprises lozériennes nous avons seul
piloter et pleinement coordonnées la
collecte en mettant à disposition un
lieu de stockage tout en assurant le
ramassage dans les mairies devenu pour
l'occasion point de collecte je tiens
d'ailleurs à saluer l'investissement des
maires et des élus de notre territoire
qui se sont associés à notre démarche
tout comme je remercie l'Union
départementale des sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires et des jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers de Lozère ainsi que
tous les agents du Département qui se
sont mobilisés tout au long de la
collecte
donc le premier qu'on voit humanitaire
de France partait de la Lozère le 5 mars
au total trois convois humanitaires fut
respectée à la frontière polonaise puis
en direction des hôpitaux de livres et
de zitomir
dans ce contexte une famille de bourses
Cologne de notre département a pris
l'initiative d'aller récupérer un
Slovaquie des amis qui avait fui les
bombardements intensifs de leur ville
mandaté par cette famille les transports
Hugon acceptèrent de faire le voyage
arriver à Bratislava les deux
conducteurs confrontés à l'ampleur de la
catastrophe humanitaire en cours nous
ont contacté pour nous informer qu'ils
ne repartiraient pas avec un bus à
moitié vide et qui ne resterait pas sans
rien faire devant des femmes et des
enfants qui dormaient à même le sol
depuis plusieurs jours
nous nous sommes alors rapprochés de
l'ambassade de France à Bratislava pour
les uns pour informer les autorités que
ce bus allait venir en France avec un
son bord 34 personnes tout en demandant
la possibilité de procéder à une
vérification des documents d'identité
l'attaché d'ambassade nous signifiait
qu'un tel contrôle exigé un délai de
plus de 15 jours et que
la situation il nous conseilla de faire
rentrer malgré tout en France le bus
avec les familles tout en précisant que
les contrôles d'identité pourraient se
faire auprès des services préfectoraux
de la Lozère
informer de leur arrivée pour le samedi
12 mars le directeur de cabinet pour
anticiper au mieux les formalités à
demander à être destinataire d'une copie
des passeport de tous les autres
documents que chacun des passagers avait
un sa possession
ses copies qui furent adressées
rapidement et à une heure du matin dans
la nuit du vendredi 11 au samedi 12 sont
adressés à la préfecture donc le samedi
12 mars au matin les familles bénévoles
étaient sur place à l'arrivée du bus
pour accueillir les réfugiés ukrainiens
alors si les hébergers tous ensemble
dans une structure d'accueil pouvait
faciliter le travail des administrations
nous avons fait le choix de
l'intégration dans des familles
donc dans la foulée une cellule
d'accueil d'urgence composée d'acides
sociales de psychologues de médecins et
depuis recrutrice tous agents du
Département étaient mobilisés pour faire
les premiers examens et délivrer les
premières aides urgences en présence de
traductrices pour faciliter la
communication
afin d'obtenir les autorisations
provisoires de séjour nous avons demandé
des rendez-vous auprès du bureau des
étrangers de la préfecture et le
département le Conseil départemental a
financer la traduction de plus de 1000
documents auprès de traducteurs agréés
afin d'obtenir ces mêmes autorisations
à ce stade nous avons rencontré des
difficultés
ces difficultés venaient du manque de
directives des ministères concernés
plongeant les agents du bureau des
étrangers dans le désarroi au point de
nous demander d'aller avec les familles
aux différents points de contrôle
frontaliers pour obtenir le tampon
d'entrée dans l'espace Schengen ce que
nous avons refusé
sur le plan de l'éducation tous les
enfants ont été et sont toujours
inscrits dans des écoles élémentaires
collèges et lycées et nous avons mis en
place des cours de français pour des
adultes les adolescents en partenariat
avec le CDIF
plus d'un mois après le début du conflit
les services de l'État ont reçu un
Lozère des familles qu'ils ont logé dans
un complexe et se sont appuyés sur notre
expérience et notre travail depuis le 25
février
toujours dans un souci d'intégration
nous avons sollicité les entreprises
lozériennes pour permettre à ces
réfugiés de retrouver un peu de vie
normale et d'autonomie à travers le
travail
[Applaudissements]
et puis un autre exemple de difficultés
rencontrées c'est qu'une personne
méprisant parfaitement la langue
française aurait souhaité devenir
traductrice interprète à cermanter
auprès des tribunaux ce qui nous aurait
facilité les choses mais malheureusement
elle ne peut pas créer son entreprise sa
micro-entreprise car elle est détentrice
d'un numéro de sécurité sociale
temporaire donc bon voilà donc à l'heure
où je m'adresse à vous je peux vous
dresser un bilan plutôt positif en effet
le choix que nous avons fait qui est
celui de l'immersion dans les familles
d'accueil de l'apprentissage du français
et de l'emploi ont permis à tous ces
adultes de s'intégrer de trouver un
emploi et d'avoir des enfants scolarisés
un clair de retrouver un semblant de vie
normale et d'autonomie même si le
département est toujours vigilant et
toujours à leur écoute
fort de notre expérience acquise sur le
tas et du fait que nous avons été le
premier département nous mobilisé aussi
rapidement d'autres collectivités comme
la région Occitanie le département de
l'Aude du Gers etc nous ont sollicité
pour profiter de notre expérience et
expertise aujourd'hui une coopération
décentralisée existe en Lozère via la
commune de Chanac qui est jumelée avec
la ville de tchernistie
et pour le département nous
réfléchissons actuellement à des actes
de coopération décentralisée qui reste à
définir je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
Madame Delmas je crois savoir qu'on peut
être à nouveau en liaison avec Madame
Marina arkava la vice mère de Tcherkassy
oui
non mais on peut qu'on lui donne on peut
je suis ravalement qu'on peut mais
merci d'être à nouveau avec nous et je
vous rends immédiatement la parole
priorité de notre travail et
d'implication des investissements dans
la vie de tcherkasi et nous serons très
reconnaissants de votre soutien dans le
domaine suivant suivant les
infrastructures de construction donc de
d'usines transformation des déchets la
modernisation de système de
d'approvisionnement en eau et la
recherche des sources alternatives
d'énergie la restauration de travail de
l'aéroport de tcherkasi et également
nous avons besoin d'urgence des projets
de d'économie d'énergie l'efficacité
d'éclairage
urbain de la restauration de la centrale
solaire
la création des éclairages LED dans les
bâtiments publics
création des sources d'approvision à nos
chaude pour les crèches forcément des
piscines nous avons quatre avec
l'utilisation des pompes également la
création de la zone de récréation
moderne dans la ville de Tcherkassy et
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
le fait que dans la mesure où dans notre
région il y a beaucoup de déplacés
internes nous avons également besoin
d'aide en matière de réhabilitation de
nos défenseurs notamment en France et
peut-être la révélation psychologique en
France pour les enfants des personnes
déplacées internes
étant donné qu'il y a un grand nombre de
se déplacer se trouvent dans notre ville
nous considérons comme prioritaire la
création des centres de shorters où les
gens puissent vivre la dernière nous
avons restauré
des bâtiments et après aujourd'hui près
de 500 personnes mais cette année nos
ambitionnons de construire
d'autres grands sites pour loger les
déplacer internes nous serons très
reconnaissants si
viennent nous accorder une aide
technique dans l'équipement de ces
bâtiments donc
les équipements
sanitaires les lits etc nous essayons de
couvrir tout cela avec les moyens de
notre budget notamment la restauration
de bâtiments mais ne seront
reconnaissants pour tout aide et soutien
de notre ville de ceux qui
ont trouvé un refuge et pour le soutien
de l'Ukraine de manière générale merci
infiniment gloire à l'Ukraine et gloire
à la France
merci à nos amis ukrainiens
et je ne doute pas que les appels lancés
seront entendues dans cette salle je
vais tout de suite donner la parole pour
son retour d'expérience à Monsieur
Thibault Guignard maire de bleu clair
mitage qu'au président de la commission
Europe de l'Association des maires de
France président de la délégation
française au Congrès des pouvoirs locaux
et régionaux du Conseil de l'Europe vous
avez la parole merci beaucoup monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs bonjour
à toutes et à tous dans vos grades et
qualité je suis très heureux d'être cet
après-midi au Sénat pour cette table
ronde qui nous permet de faire un bilan
de plus d'un an de solidarité entre les
collectivités locales françaises et les
collectivités locales ukrainiennes et
puis surtout tracer des perspectives
pour la suite pour cette guerre qui n'en
finit pas et bien évidemment pour la
reconstruction que nous espérons le plus
rapidement le plus rapide possible
alors les collectivités locales et
particulièrement l'échelon municipal a
eu un lieu un rôle particulier dès le
début de la guerre puisque les mères
sont aux avant-postes de l'accueil
notamment des 115 000 réfugiés
Ukrainiens en France avec la mise à
disposition de logement de repas de
cours de français de scolarisation pour
les enfants on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure avec l'exemple de la Lozère les
communes ont également apportées un
soutien important aux collectivités
ukrainiennes les communes et les villes
et qui sont passées par des partenaires
reconnus comme la protection civile qui
a également fait un bilan tout à l'heure
mais aussi grâce à d'autres ONG elles
sont nombreuses à s'être mobilisées pour
la mise en relation des communes et des
villes françaises et ukrainiennes et je
pense notamment à l'ONG est Stains du
sucrain qui est représenté dans
l'assemblée aujourd'hui donc ce
formidable mouvement de solidarité
dévoiler le transformer en véritable
coopération entre les différentes
collectivités il faut savoir qu'avant la
guerre il n'y avait que que seulement 30
jumelage entre des collectivités
françaises et des collectivités
ukrainiennes alors même que pour la
comparaison il y avait 300 coopérations
entre collectivités françaises et
collectivités polonaise issus notamment
de la période de solidarnosque et dès
2018 avec l'Association Française du
Conseil des communes des régions
d'Europe monsieur le Président nous
avions souhaité profité de ces nombres
importants de coopération Franco
polonaise pour tisser des liens avec les
collectivités ukrainiennes et nous
avions organisé à Saint-Brieuc des
assises franco-polonaises ouvertes aux
partenaires Ukrainiens pour essayer de
s'appuyer sur des coopérations
tripartite qui fonctionne très bien avec
la Pologne mais aussi avec d'autres pays
comme la Roumanie
alors aujourd'hui toute la question
c'est la question de la mise en relation
des des communes et des villes entre
elles c'est-à-dire que les communes et
les villes françaises sont nombreuses à
vouloir avoir des partenariats avec des
homologues
Ukrainiens mais pour autant il faut
réussir cette mise en relation et il y a
eu beaucoup d'initiatives qui ont été
prises bien évidemment l'Association des
maires de France qui a mis en relation
des collectivités entre elles la fccrre
et des exemples ont été donnés tout à
l'heure de nombreuses ONG et puis
l'initiative du Congrès des pouvoirs
locaux du Conseil de l'Europe qui a créé
un site cities forcesities qui vise à
mettre en relation des collectivités
européennes qui souhaitent collaborer
coopérer aider des collectivités
ukrainiennes
pour que ces coopérations fonctionnent
il faut des actions concrètes et ça a
été très bien dit à l'instant par
François Richet des actions concrètes
qui permettent
aux élus de voir à quoi servent les
moyens déployés par les collectivités
locales mais aussi aux citoyens car si
on veut faire accepter cet élan de
générosité et ses coopérations
décentralisées par nos par nos
concitoyens qui la financent à travers
leurs impôts locaux ou nationaux et bien
il faut que nous ayons des actions
concrètes c'est ce qui a été fait à
travers les générateurs c'est ce qui a
été fait aussi à travers des opérations
spécifiques pour l'aide à la scolarité
c'est ce qui pourrait être fait
maintenant pour répondre à la question
de la qualité de l'eau en fournissant
des systèmes de filtrage de l'eau
potable puisque tous les systèmes
d'adduction d'eau sont aujourd'hui
défectueux dans le dans le pays et
notamment sur la zone de front et donc
il y a besoin de ces actions concrètes
donc là dans certaines situation c'est
la coopération qui va permettre de
mettre en place des actions concrètes et
d'autres fois c'est des actions
concrètes entre deux partenaires qui ne
se connaissaient pas avant qui vont
permettre de mettre en place des
coopérations durables l'agglomération de
Saint-Brieuc au sein de laquelle je suis
vice-président en charge d'affaires
européenne a ainsi rencontré grâce aux
dons de générateur la commune d'ovrouth
à la frontière biélorusse une des villes
les premières bombardées au premier jour
de l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine et
j'ai pu me rendre sur place afin de
renforcer les liens entre
l'agglomération de Saint-Brieuc et la
commune de Woods et puis il y a une
autre action qui est portée par le
Comité européen des régions c'est
l'action pour les camps d'été de façon à
accueillir cet été des jeunes Ukrainiens
en séjour on va pas dire de vacances
mais de dépaysement pour les changer un
petit peu du quotidien pour leur faire
découvrir notre pays et je pense que de
nombreuses villes qui ont des centres de
loisirs qui ont des centres de choisir
avec hébergement peuvent s'inscrire dans
cette initiative des des camps d'été et
puis il viendra ensuite la période de la
reconstruction où là les collectivités
françaises pourront avoir deux rôles
genre en tout cas moi j'en vois deux
principaux le premier c'est le rôle
d'expertise pour apporter notamment sur
sur des expertises spécifiques je pense
à l'eau à l'assainissement aux déchets à
la reconstruction des bâtiments qui
pourront sans doute davantage passer
d'ailleurs par l'échelon intercommunal
que par l'échelon communal puisque c'est
bien de l'intercommunalité en France que
dépend de ces grandes compétences et
puis l'autre action possible pour les
collectivités c'est de jouer le tiers de
confiance notamment pour mobiliser des
financements de l'Union européenne de
l'ONU de l'AFD des financements qui
seront sans doute et nous l'espérons
nombreux et généreux mais pour lesquels
les collectivités locales peuvent jouer
ce rôle de tiers de confiance pour dans
le cadre d'un consortium avec des
collectivités d'autres nationalités
européennes et des collectivités
ukrainiennes pouvoir mobiliser ces fonds
nécessaires pour pour la reconstruction
et donc il me semble important de
pouvoir accompagner dès maintenant nos
partenaires dans cette perspective de
reconstruction parce que c'est aussi ce
tracé un avenir se donner de l'espoir de
la perspective pour la suite après après
la guerre et j'ai rencontré récemment le
maire de Mario Paul qui a créé ce
programme de reconstruction de Mario
Paul qui s'appelle Reborn myopole et qui
est vraiment exceptionnel car les élus
craignaient je voudrais terminer par là
en leur rendant hommage des élus
Ukrainiens une capacité de résistance et
de résilience qui est vraiment
remarquable pour avoir visité plusieurs
villes lors de passage en Ukraine au
mois d'avril j'ai pu voir combien chacun
se projetait dans la reconstruction qui
a déjà commencé dans les territoires
bombardés des février 2022 et qui sont
un peu en répit aujourd'hui qui a déjà
qui a déjà commencé et là les élus
craignaient ont pris toutes leurs
responsabilités responsabilité de
responsable de la de la Garde rép
ublicaine et des volontaires qui doivent
préparer la défense de des communes et
des villages mais aussi leur
responsabilité pour la reconstruction et
pour donner aux Ukrainiens aux
ukrainiennes l'espoir d'un avenir
meilleur et donc les collectivités
françaises et les communes à travers
notamment l'Association des maires de
France seront à leur côté dans cette
reconstruction merci monsieur le
président
merci à vous Monsieur le Maire je vais
donner la parole à Madame Véronique
Berthol adjointe au maire de Strasbourg
mais comme je dois aller présider la
séance je vais demander à mon collègue
Jean-François Rapin de bien vouloir
venir faire modérateur non sans avoir
salué d'ailleurs nos collègues sénateurs
présents j'ai vu Bruno Belin j'ai vu
Jean-Yves Leconte j'en ai peut-être raté
je m'excuse au moment où je dis ça
rentre Florence Gatel évidemment
Françoise Gatel pardon juste pile poil
parce qu'elle veut être saluée il y a
pas de raison merci merci en tout cas à
vous bonne continuation de cette table
ronde je te cède la parole pour aller
présider
merci beaucoup mesdames messieurs en vos
grades des qualités bonjour à toutes et
à tous et merci pour cette invitation
pour vous présenter le fond de
solidarité pour l'Ukraine de cités
Unifrance alors si tes Unifrance c'est
un réseau de collectivités territoriales
françaises engagée dans l'action
internationale
et nous avions prévu une présentation
c'est bon
voilà merci beaucoup
suite à l'agression russe en Ukraine en
février 2022 si tes Unis France en
partenariat avec cité et gouvernement
locaux unis et j'ai lu et le Conseil des
communes et régions d'Europe ont décidé
d'ouvrir un fond de solidarité pour
l'Ukraine alors les fonds de solidarité
à citations c'est quelque chose de
récurrent dans le but de favoriser la
reconstruction à la résilience des
territoires à la suite d'une crise
quelconque elle peut être naturel comme
les séismes en Syrie et Turquie
dernièrement si tes Unies France lance
en général un appel à contribution aux
collectivités françaises pour une action
collective partagée cuff et ses
partenaires locaux identifient ensuite
les besoins du territoire un plan de
travail est proposé discuter validé avec
les donateurs du fond
Cuffe ensuite les activités dédiées et
se chargent du suivi tout au long de son
déroulement il s'agit donc pour les
collectivités d'effectuer un don qui
sera affecté à un projet précis
correspondant à des besoins locaux
identifiés l'objectif spécifique du fond
solidarité
Ukraine était de soutenir les
collectivités ukrainiennes et les
collectivités des pays frontaliers dans
leur capacité à accueillir des personnes
déplacées du crâne et à fournir des
services publics essentiels alors à ce
jour 22 collectivités territoriales
françaises et CGLU ont contribué au fond
ce qu'on peut voir
après voilà la liste Strasbourg par
exemple a contribué en tant que ville et
Eurométropole
ou même montant que la ville et l'euro
métropole ont contribué au fait écho au
passage il y a peut-être d'autres
collectivités donatrices dans la salle
alors
le fond on a décidé d'agir en trois
programmes dans trois territoires
différents
ces programmes sont actuellement en
cours le premier programme c'est le
soutien à l'association des villes
ukrainiennes à UC
l'objectif c'est de soutenir les
municipalités
ukrainiennes les plus touchées par
l'agression russe
dans leur fonctionnement dans leur cas
dans leur activité quotidiennes soutenir
aussi la UC comme on l'a vu tout à
l'heure la situation est devenue
particulièrement critique cet hiver avec
des besoins croissants en
infrastructures en équipements en
chauffage et pour ce programme trois
volets d'activités le premier est de
fournir des équipements bureautiques
véhicules dans 10 municipalités des
régions de soumis carquis fait doniak
pour qu'elle puisse continuer à répondre
aux urgences et aux besoins essentiels
de leur citoyens maintenir des services
de base
le deuxième volet c'est de soutenir et
renforcer les capacités de l'Association
des villes ukrainiennes en modernisant
leurs outils de travail ordinateur
serveur etc
cette association s'est vu confié des
nouvelles tâches avec avec l'agression
russe notamment de coordonner toute
l'action humanitaire de surveiller les
mères enlevées parce qu'on a eu cette
petite donnée aussi à traiter et fournir
des conseils aux collectivités
ukrainiennes et enfin le troisième volet
c'est de créer de nouveaux partenariats
entre des collectivités françaises et
ukrainiennes par leur organisation de
rencontres de conférences
d'un séjour des représentants Ukrainiens
en France comme on l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises les municipalités ukrainiennes
ont beaucoup à partager avec leurs
homologues françaises
les actions de coopération et de
solidarité à prévoir et à penser plus
maintenant en post-urgence qui n'est pas
du tout la même chose
on a dit qu'on avait à peu près une
trentaine de jumelage à ce jour on
espère en avoir beaucoup plus à l'avenir
voilà peut-être pour visualiser un peu
et on voit effectivement cher cassis au
milieu de l'Ukraine le deuxième
programme
qui a été sélectionné c'est un soutien
aux collectivités moldave qui accueille
des personnes déplacées d'Ukraine alors
selon le les chiffres du Haut
commissariat au réfugiés des Nations
Unies plus de 100 000 personnes
déplacées du crâne ont trouvé refuge en
Moldavie depuis le début de l'agression
russe les municipalités moldavres sont
donc confrontés à un défi d'accueillir
le flux de réfugiés de fournir des
services publics et de favoriser leur
insertion l'objectif donc de ce
programme c'est de soutenir les
initiatives locales conduisant à
l'amélioration de la situation des
réfugiés leur intégration dans les dans
les dans la communauté la société en
général assurer la cohésion sociale avec
la population locale on est sur les
mêmes problématiques que ici en France
et renforcer bien sûr les capacités des
collectivités territoriales en gestion
de crise donc le projet a été mis en
oeuvre avec le calme congress of local
autorities
dans 17
villes moldave sélectionnées par un
appel à projet et une convention a été
signée entre cités-unis France et le
calme
alors pour les exemples de projets donc
j'ai voulu mettre un petit peu des
photos pour humaniser nos propos on a on
est sur de l'amélioration et
réhabilitation de centre d'accueil
construction de blogs sanitaires d'air
de jeux pour enfants pour les enfants
d'amélioration de l'éclairage public les
ateliers d'artisanat et de
d'autonomisation économique
voilà à ce jour 17 municipalités moldave
ont été approchées les projets sont
quasiment clos en tout cas la clôture du
programme est en cours et enfin le
dernier
ça c'est encore les photos de Moldavie
le troisième et dernier programme c'est
le soutien à la ville de
je prononce pas très bien pardon qui
accueille aussi des personnes déplacées
du crâne voilà une ville polonaise de
200 000 habitants frontalières avec
l'Ukraine qui accueille aujourd'hui près
de 30 000 réfugiés et les principaux
besoins auxquels fassent la ville
concerne l'installation à moyen et long
terme pour les personnes déplacées du
crâne donc là encore l'objectif c'est de
favoriser l'intégration sociale et
économique d'un groupe de 25 femmes
ukrainiennes
âgées de 18 à 60 ans leur permettre de
travailler de placer les enfants à la
crèche ou à l'école de réaliser avec
elle des démarches administratives de
créer du lien social de les aider à
trouver leur place dans la société tout
ce qui est rendu possible en fait par
l'activation de la directive protection
temporaire de la Commission européenne
le type d'activité mise en place c'est
des rencontres individuelles avec un
conseiller professionnel des ateliers
d'orientation professionnelle en groupe
des cours de polonais adaptés aux
besoins individuels des formations en
compétences professionnelles et un
soutien psychologique ce programme est
toujours en cours de réalisation
en conclusion un échange en visio avec
le comité des donateurs et les
partenaires Ukrainiens polonais et
moldave a eu lieu le 6 juillet dernier
donc vendredi dernier pour présenter les
différents projets dont je vous ai parlé
leur état d'avancement une visite sur le
terrain en Ukraine est envisagé
également pour la fin de l'année là
aussi c'est la volonté du comité des
donateurs d'aller à la rencontre des
villes ukrainiennes soutenues et de leur
rendre hommage pour leur résistance et
résilience et puis une autre visite est
prévue également alors cette fois-ci des
villes ukrainiennes mais ici en France
de les accueillir voilà 6 ou 7 villes
qui aurait été soutenue par le fond
le programme est en cours d'élaboration
nous espérons pouvoir être reçus
également au Sénat et puis faire
peut-être encore une un tour de France
de certaines collectivités françaises
Strasbourg se porte également volontaire
pour accueillir une des étapes de ce
Tour de France
alors pas seulement pour les tout ce que
nous avions mis en place
depuis le début de du conflit mais
surtout pour par le fait qu'on accueille
sur notre territoire le Conseil de
l'Europe qui est en train de faire un
énorme travail notamment par rapport au
registre des dommages qui devraient être
opérationnel d'ici la fin de l'année
donc vraiment enregistré tout et garder
et consigner en fait tout ce qui se
passe actuellement
le Congrès des pouvoirs locaux fait
partie du Conseil de l'Europe la
délégation
ukrainienne est très active de même qu'à
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe donc ça ferait sens qu'on
accueille une partie en tout cas une
étape de ce Tour de France
et il me reste une toute petite minute
je voulais juste revenir sur ce que la
ville de Strasbourg a mis en place
depuis le début du conflit alors bien
sûr on a été très réactif dans l'urgence
et notamment avec le Port autonome de
Strasbourg transformé en plateforme
logistique pour
récolter puis envoyer tous les dons
collectés par la protection civile nous
avons mis en place dix jours après le
début du conflit un centre de
pré-accueil en lien avec les services de
l'État les Hôpitaux Universitaires de
Strasbourg
les bailleurs pour l'hébergement
nous avons contribué au fosséco face à
coup je l'ai dit par contre là c'est
vrai qu'en entrant dans la phase de
poste
urgence il faut prendre son temps il y a
urgence à prendre son temps pour
construire des coopérations qui feront
du sens à l'avenir
et c'est là où on a besoin encore nous
d'un tout petit peu de temps bien sûr
continuer les dons de matériel la balle
et dont la nature on a parlé des
générateurs mais il y a aussi encore des
besoins en véhicule ou en
matériel pour l'assainissement et l'eau
continuez à accueillir des délégations
je les dis Strasbourg Conseil de
l'Europe on accueille régulièrement des
délégations du crâne donc ça on reste on
garde la porte ouverte continuer à
sensibiliser ici pour nos propres
populations
continuent à parler de ce qui se passe
en Ukraine donc pour ça on dédiera une
partie de notre célèbre Marché de Noël
on accueillera voilà des chalets
ukrainiens
et puis une
un autre projet je pense assez
atypique et assez vite oui en
collaboration avec Arte donc à
Strasbourg on accueille aussi le siège
d'Arte et Arte et le Conseil de l'Europe
ont réuni des documentaristes
du crème pour développer et financer une
douzaine de films documentaires pour
raconter la guerre qui s'y déroule donc
voilà tout ça dans l'objectif de garder
des traces c'est un peu comme le
registre des dommages garder des traces
témoigner pour l'avenir voilà notre
contribution un petit peu différente
merci pour votre écoute et à merci
Madame Berthol alors simplement vous
dire que vous avez fait un parallèle
entre le choc l'urgence et puis le plus
long terme et là aussi je le dis aux
collectivité française vous pouvez avoir
des échanges particuliers avec les
Polonais vous l'avez dit la région de
chichou mais aussi les Slovaques qui eux
ont eu ce choc et aujourd'hui
ont aussi une forme de résilience par
rapport à l'accueil et aux coopérations
qui sont mises en place moi je suis allé
sur place à plusieurs reprises en tout
cas bien étons en mesure d'avoir un
échange avec nos homologues à bah très
bien voilà donc moi j'aimerais que qu'il
puisse réagir quelques minutes
avant qu'on fasse la pose et je vous le
dis on n'aura pas d'échanger avec la
salle parce que on a pris beaucoup de
retard mais enfin c'est un retard bien
ordonné et bien organisé
monsieur le Président ou vice-président
Madame la Maire je sais pas qui qui veut
prendre la parole pour réagir à ce qui a
été dit
je vous en prie
allez-y prenez la parole dans l'ordre
qui vous sert moi je
peut-être je vous vois réagir donc
bon
il y a pas de demande de prise de parole
bon je considère que donc tout ce qui a
été dit
à
satisfait pleinement nos homologues
Ukrainiens ah oui monsieur le Président
je vous prie donc m'excuser je vais des
ruptures de connexion voilà mes jeux
je voudrais juste vous remercier pour
cet échange qui qui nous a beaucoup
enrichi parce que beaucoup de bons
exemples et bonnes pratiques d'aide nous
sommes maintenant très utiles et nous
sommes très heureux d'apprendre que les
camps d'été vont être organisés pour nos
enfants
Ukrainiens je sais que CPF a été
associée de sécurité populaire français
moi je suis aussi un membre de cette
association et j'attends le congrès de
cette association à l'automne c'est un
très bon projet il y en a d'autres et
vraiment je voudrais souligner à quel
point il est important maintenant de
faire les projets à long terme les plus
les projets structurants et nos
instances de donc de nos collectivités
territorielles sont prêts pour cette
coopération commençons
merci merci à vous et puis désolé pour
ces petits soucis de connexion mais
peut-être quelqu'un d'autre veut prendre
la parole chez vous
non vraisemblablement pas bien écoutez
on va clore cette cette première table
ronde donc je suis désolé qu'on qu'on
donne pas la parole à la salle mais vous
l'avez compris on a on a quelque peu de
retard donc on va assurer une petite
pause quelques quelques minutes et je
vous demande de revenir sans horaires
précis mais le plus vite possible en
tout cas dans cette salle pour entamer
la deuxième table ronde je vous remercie
s'il vous plaît
si tout le monde est revenu madame la
présidente du groupe d'amitié francs
Ukraine
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs Mesdames et
Messieurs les Présidents Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires élus locaux
mes chers collègues
Mesdames et Messieurs les représentants
d'associations de collectivités
territoriales mesdames et messieurs il
me revient donc l'honneur de modérer la
seconde session de cette table ronde qui
porte sur l'engagement des collectivités
territoriales françaises en faveur de la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine les
initiatives se multiplient pour
accompagner la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine c'est un vrai défi je le
mesure bien pour mettre rendu sur place
avec le président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher il y a déjà un an et avoir
constaté la désolation des destructions
subies par ce pays mais c'est aussi une
perspective d'espoir pour nous tous la
France a organisé le 13 décembre 2022 la
conférence bilatérale pour la résilience
et la reconstruction de l'Ukraine
Berlin est encore plus récemment Londres
ont aussi organisé des conférences
similaires d'autres sont encore à venir
comme la conférence organisée à Varsovie
en novembre prochain la nomination par
le Président de la République d'un
envoyé spécial pour l'aide et la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine en la
personne de Monsieur pierrelbronn est
également un signal fort celui-ci en
déplacement en Ukraine n'a pu se joindre
à nous l'Union européenne a aussi mis en
place ses propres dispositifs on pense
par exemple à la plateforme Rebell you
crane les organisations internationales
ne sont pas en reste puisqu'elles
travaillent aussi sur la nécessaire
reconstruction de l'Ukraine même si il
est difficile de faire une estimation
précise la Banque mondiale a estimé à ce
jour le montant des réparations
qu'implique la guerre en Ukraine à 400
milliards de dollars c'est considérable
nous avons abordé la question en mai
dernier à Stockholm avec les
parlementaires de tous les États membres
de l'Union réunis pour la cosaque la
conférence des organes spécialisés en
affaires communautaire comme chaque
semaine le chef de la représentation de
la Banque européenne d'investissement en
Ukraine Jean-Éric de zagon nous a
précisé que pour le seul déminage 38
milliards de dollars seraient
nécessaires une partie défend nécessaire
pourrait provenir des chorus gelées en
application des sanctions européennes
mais cela n'est pas simple au plan
juridique en tout cas tous s'accordent
pour que la priorité aille à la
reconstruction des villes des routes et
des écoles pour faciliter le retour des
réfugiés
pour l'ensemble de ces initiatives les
collectivités territoriales jouent un
rôle essentiel reconstruire l'Ukraine ne
saurait se faire sans la participation
pleine et entière des collectivités pour
que cette reconstruction repose sur des
bases démocratiques solides au plus près
des citoyens en filigrane c'est aussi
l'adhésion du pays à l'Union européenne
qui est en jeu un sujet que je suis avec
une attention particulière sur ce volet
l'expérience de nos collectivités de
leurs élus et de leur fonctionnaires en
matière de gouvernance de
décentralisation et de mise en oeuvre de
politique publique locale est un atout
certain nos collectivités ont donc
toutes légitimité à s'investir dans le
champ de la reconstruction et en faveur
de la résilience des institutions la
connaissance du tissu économique local
ukrainien est une opportunité pour mener
à bien les programmes d'accompagnement
qui soient pertinents et efficace
les entreprises françaises par leur
savoir-faire ont toute leur place dans
cette reconstruction les collectivités
locales peuvent aussi porter ce message
et les y aider avec le soutien
d'opérateur tels que la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie
franco-ukrainienne et business France
qui connaissent parfaitement le pays et
ses enjeux
quelles sont les clés de cette seconde
session de notre table ronde
et je passe sans plus attendre la parole
à Monsieur Vitali maletski participant
en vision-conférence qui émerve de
cremenciuk cette ville qui a été
durement touchée et dont l'un des
centres commerciaux a été bombardé en
juin 2022 par l'armée russe Monsieur le
Maire c'est à vous si vous êtes
en connexion
cher participant de la table ronde mais
collègues français et ukrainiens
les représentants des chambres de
commerce on s'appelle des organisations
internationales des entreprises etc je
vous remercie beaucoup de la possibilité
de prendre part à ces tables rondes et
te présenter notre vision des
perspectives de coopération entre les
municipalités françaises et
ukrainiennes en matière de
reconstruction tout d'abord je voudrais
remercier le peuple français les
dirigeants français pour leur position
ferme en matière de soutien de l'Ukraine
pour votre aide dès les premiers jours
et c'était et extrêmement précieuse pour
nous et là ça déclinaison dans la
matière militaire humanitaire politique
des sanctions etc je vous remercie
d'être à nos côtés dans la défense de la
liberté de l'indépendance de l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui en Ukraine il y a dans le
monde il n'y a peut-être pas un autre
pays où il y a tant besoin de coordonner
de réunir les efforts de tous pour
restaurer les sites
médicaux sociaux les logements vous avez
tout à fait raison de souligner que le
pays se trouve maintenant face à un
nouveau défi lorsqu'il faudrait faire
tout cela relativement vite afin de
permettre à nos concitoyens de revenir
dans leur pays d'avoir accès à
l'éducation à la médecine et à au
logement décent aujourd'hui la Russie
commet de nouveau crime de guerre en
détruisant les nouveaux sites il n'y a
pas longtemps ils ont commis un acte
d'écocide en faisant dynamiter le
barrage de carroufka en mettant des
centaines de milliers de personnes à la
limite de survie en limitant leur accès
à des choses aussi banales telles que
l'eau potable aujourd'hui il menace le
monde entier avec un nouvel action
terroriste à la centrale de zaporiges
mais nous croyons que tous ensemble nous
sommes capables de protéger la vie et de
surmonter les destructions
provoquées par la Russie car dès
aujourd'hui nous parlons de la
reconstruction et nous parlons
aujourd'hui des sites à reconstruire
permettant le développement stable de
l'Ukraine et de ses relations avec
l'Union européenne nos communautés ont
besoin d'un soutien total dans cette
reconstruction en particulier en matière
de finances les experts matériels
techniques etc nous sommes prêtes à
préparer des projets et ainsi à les
financer grâce à la Commission
européenne mais nous avons besoin des
partenaires en France ou dans des villes
des organisations qui nous permettraient
à préparer le cadre répondant aux
exigences européennes et ce sera la
première pas pour l'implantation de
l'entrée de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne ne pourront remonter à un
autre niveau la responsabilité
local nos compétences qui se déploient
au niveau local dans nos entreprises
communes aujourd'hui la ville de
cremenshuk en raison des
des attaques des missiles c'est l'usine
de transformation de pétrolière qui a
été détruite entièrement une centrale
thermique qui a assuré 180 000 logements
en chauffage dans la ville de Clemenceau
le pire des actions terroristes que vous
devenez d'évoquer c'est une frappe
contre le centre commercial encore la
veille de la fête nationale ukrainienne
le soir lorsqu'il y a des centaines de
personnes dans ce centre 22 personnes
ont été mortes et 130 ont été blessées
aujourd'hui nous parlons de
besoin aujourd'hui
malgré les menaces des frappes de
préparer les systèmes de chauffage pour
les nouveaux défis grâce au soutien de
nos partenaires européens le du
président
Zelinski la ville de cremenshuk a reçu
une aide et de partir des réserves de
l'État je profite de l'occasion pour
remercier français pour 40 groupes
électrogènes qui avaient des transmis
cet hiver qui ont permis d'assurer le
survie de la ville en temps de chauffage
et d'assurer l'accouchement en
électricité des villes et des villages
de l'Ukraine alors que nos
qualités et pouvaient rester sans
électricité pendant 10 heures d'affilée
nous savons que c'était une décision
provisoire et que nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui d'un élaborer un système
stable pour pouvoir être paré face aux
attaques futures puisque de nouveau les
Russes utiliseront ce genre d'attaque
pour faire pression sur le peuple
craignant et sur chaque craignant
habitant dans les villes de les villages
et d'ailleurs vous êtes déjà nous savons
que nous sommes plus forts qu'avant
grâce notamment à votre aide
maintenant tout le monde comprend que
forcément l'Ukraine est un territoire
capable de contribuer au développement
des sociétés européennes les
investissements qui viendront à Ukraine
qui pourront être utilisés différemment
par nom municipalité par nos villes
notre communauté a un grand potentiel de
développement de l'économie régionale
mais pour cela nous avons des
investissements en particulier dans le
domaine de technologie des connaissances
et développement des infrastructures
locales de protection de l'environnement
de l'économie d'énergie etc nous
souhaitons que nos partenaires français
puissent venir et travailler dans le
domaine municipal mais aussi dans le
domaine des affaires nous avons une
entreprise française Danone qui
travaille de manière très efficace dans
notre pays cette société avait deux
usines à Ukraine une après-midi personne
cette usine a été entièrement détruite
par les occupants russes
plus continuer à fonctionner à payer ses
impôts à offrir les emplois à des
centaines d'habitants de notre ville
dans notre
usine et de les sociétés qui travaillent
avec l'usine nous disons aujourd'hui que
à l'Ukraine malgré la guerre il y a un
investissement d'investissement qui est
très favorable parce qu'il y a des gens
qui travaillent qui sont prêtes à
continuer à développer le les affaires à
créer les emplois à construire le
logement les sites d'infrastructures
nous sommes intéressés à prendre par des
programmes cadres de la Commission
européenne que j'ai déjà évoqué et si
nous avons besoin de soutien et de
collaboration des partenaires et des
villes européennes nous étudions
actuellement à la possibilité de signer
des accords de coopération et des
accords de jumelage avec les villes de
France et nous les remercions d'être
réceptifs à nos demandes aujourd'hui
nous parlons de la nécessité de
restaurer et de développer le crâne les
villes européennes pour nous ce sont des
exemples de bons gouvernance des changes
d'expérience la communication avec les
maires avec les spécialistes nous
donnent des exemples de la bonne et
efficace gouvernance des territoires et
des communautés mesdames et messieurs je
tiens à remercier le peuple français
remercier tous les pays de l'Union
européenne pour le soutien constant et
l'aide à porter à l'Ukraine
d'après les résultats de notre
communication nous pourrons passer à la
formalisation à la signature des accords
et des programmes communs mais les
premiers pas ont déjà été accomplis
lorsque les premiers jours de cette
guerre vous nous avez soutenu vous nous
avez apporté votre aide nous nous en
souvenons ne l'oublierons pas et nous
vous remercions de cette aide inestimale
car c'est grâce à elle que le crâne a
tenu que le crâne continue à tenir et
que l'Ukraine gagnera sans faute je vous
remercie gloire à l'Ukraine
merci Monsieur le Maire de ce témoignage
précis et puis finalement emprunt
d'espoir parce que vous parlez
effectivement reconstruction et je crois
que les pays membres de l'Union
européenne vont vous y aider c'est clair
aujourd'hui nous allons maintenant
laisser la parole à Philippe Laurent qui
est maire de Sceaux
cher Philippe président de l'Association
Française du Conseil des communes et
régions d'Europe dont l'association
s'est particulièrement investie ces
derniers mois sur le sujet de la
reconstruction Philippe c'est à toi
merci merci monsieur le Président cher
Jean-François bonjour à toutes et à tous
et merci d'avoir invité la fcce à cette
à cette table ronde
je me j'ai juste un souvenir qui m'a
beaucoup marqué c'est quelques jours
après l'invasion russe donc c'était fin
mars
donc 2022 c'était début mars 2022 nous
avions une rencontre à Nantes
qui était à laquelle elle SSR participer
et nous avons eu pour la première fois
en visio plusieurs mères Ukrainiens dont
d'ailleurs le maire de qui est fait et
je me rappelle avoir été vraiment frappé
par à la fois
l'engagement
la
fermeté
la et en même temps une forme de
sérénité aussi qui émane de nos
collègues mères
ukrainiens et
nous avons dans un instant des relations
déjà relativement anciennes avec l'Union
des Villes
ukrainiennes on n'avait pas forcément
perçu ça mais les circonstances ont fait
que je crois que l'Ukraine
a pu compter en effet bien sûr sur son
peuple très mobilisé sur son président
mais aussi sur ses mers et nous avons vu
depuis donc les débuts de cette guerre
on a eu beaucoup de rencontres comme
aujourd'hui avec
des mères ukrainiens et à chaque fois
je suis toujours à la fois ému de
constater cet engagement je veux dire
presque cette optimisme
c'est un mot qui paraît étrange mais
c'est optimisme dans
la volonté de gagner naturellement et
aussi de reconstruire leur pays et puis
la deuxième sujet un deuxième point qui
m'a frappé j'ai encore eu l'occasion de
rencontrer
je dirais tout à l'heure des élus de
d'une ville avec laquelle on va établir
un partenariat mais en fin de semaine
également rencontré le maire de Mario
Paul et
j'étais aussi absolument frappé par la
grande importance la priorité même que
tous ces élus et je pense que c'est le
cas de tout le peuple ukrainien donne à
la jeunesse
en fait il
veulent à la fois évidemment
reconstruire leur pays pour eux-mêmes
mais aussi d'abord pour leur jeunesse et
ils parlent de la jeunesse tout le temps
je le dis mes chers collègues chers amis
parce que je trouve que c'est une grande
leçon pour nous en France est-ce que à
quoi je peux faire allusion alors bon
donc le fccrre dès le départ vous le
savez donc c'est évidemment mobilisé
comme d'ailleurs l'a fait aussi
l'Association des maires de France et
d'autres associations d'élus dès lors
que cette invasion a été connue le
lendemain même moi je le souviens de ça
dans ma ville mais tout le monde ça se
souvenir là d'une très grande solidarité
qui s'est manifestée par un très grand
nombre de nos concitoyens
ce qui était d'ailleurs tout à fait à la
fois positif et rassurant évidemment au
départ c'est toujours un peu compliqué
de l'organiser tout ça mais je dois dire
que ça s'est fait assez rapidement grâce
notamment à la protection civile qui a
organisé les choses de manière
logistique très rapidement bon il a pas
ils n'ont pas pu continuer après parce
que c'était peut-être trop compliqué et
trop lourd mais en tout cas ça s'est
très bien passé et il y a eu donc
c'était Mons élan de
générosité qui s'est ainsi manifesté et
que évidemment nous avons toutes et tous
accompagnés il y a eu évidemment aussi
très rapidement l'accueil d'un certain
nombre de personnes déplacées
de famille plutôt des mères de famille
et puis leurs enfants plutôt ça qui que
nous avons
traité dans nos collectivités dans nos
communes le mieux possible et je dois
dire avec des réussites absolument
fantastiques
dans la façon dont notamment les enfants
ont pu s'intégrer dans les écoles très
rapidement en apprenant le français en
quelques mois et en étant à même même de
passer des examens comme on l'a vu avec
un exemple tout à fait remarquable enfin
bref donc je pense que pour tout ça
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et nos
collectivités territoriales ont joué et
nos associations aussi bien sûr nos
associations ont joué un rôle
extrêmement important là nous sommes
dans un temps un peu différent même si
les opérations de solidarité doivent
évidemment se poursuivre nous sommes
dans un temps un peu différent où il
s'agit en effet de regarder l'avenir de
manière donc déterminée alors je disais
tout à l'heure que la fccrre vous savez
c'est la branche française du Conseil
des communes régions d'Europe qui
travaillent qui rassemble des
associations d'élus donc de l'ensemble
des pays du Conseil de l'Europe donc
c'est donc plus large que l'Union
européenne est l'association des villes
ukrainiennes fait partie du conseil
trouver une région d'Europe c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avions donc
amorcé des relations importantes avec
cette association avec d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure Thibault guignol la cité avec un
accord en 2016 entre l'Association des
villes ukrainiennes et l'Association des
communes polonaises un premier
rendez-vous qui a eu lieu à Saint-Brieuc
en 2018 un autre atout en 2020 donc ça
c'était avant évidemment nous avons
poursuivi
poursuivi ces contacts c'était très
important d'avoir eu ces contacts avant
parce que ça a climaté donc un minima
donc la qualité de nos relations
bon je je rentre pas trop dans les
détails de de tout ça mais nous sommes
basés sur les partenariats plus
importants qui existent avec les
communes polonaises faut savoir que à
l'heure actuelle il doit y avoir à peu
près 25 à 30 villes qui ont en fait des
accords de jumelage ou de partenariat
avec des villes ukrainiennes aujourd'hui
ça va se développer naturellement mais
aujourd'hui alors que nous sommes à
plusieurs centaines avec les communes
polonaises et donc il y a eu cette ce
relais avec la Pologne qui est donc
extrêmement important et puis
enfin s'agissant évidemment de la
reconstruction s'agissant de l'avenir
donc la fccrre a participé à un projet
qui s'appelle bridge of trust les ponts
de la confiance qui est financée
conjointement par l'Union européenne et
six pays membres donateurs l'Allemagne
la Pologne la Suède le Danemark
l'Estonie et la Slovénie et cette
initiative avec ces pays à la pour but
de mettre en contact concrètement donc
des villes ukrainiennes et des
partenaires européennes en accueillant
en organisant l'accueil d'élus et de
responsables locaux ukrainien pour de
courtes visites d'études pour la France
il y a trois villes qui se sont engagées
dans ce programme donc Bourges avec la
ville de korosten La Rochelle avec la
ville d'apostolovie et la ville de
Sceaux avec zellénodolsk et nous avons
en effet reçu la semaine dernière
pendant plusieurs jours trois jours des
responsables donc élus et administratif
de ces trois communes dans chacune de
nos trois de nos trois villes
et ça a été une des rencontres qui ont
été extrêmement riches parce que d'abord
nous voyons et nous avons pu déterminer
de manière assez claire à la fois les
besoins immédiats s'agissant de qui est
donc dans la zone d'influence du barrage
qui a explosé donc il y a un vrai sujet
dans la pour la question de l'eau c'est
un sujet qui est immédiat pour lequel
donc nous allons essayer de les aider
avec nos partenaires qui qui travaillent
qui travaille la question de l'eau donc
en France
et puis plus globalement
le fait d'avoir ce contact physique elle
était évidemment majeure pour pouvoir
discuter et échanger sur les projets
d'avenir sur la façon dont on pouvait à
la fois organiser bien sûr les
institutions mais c'est pas trop ça le
sujet c'est la démocratie participative
comment dans cette reconstruction
nécessaire puisque les éléments a connu
des destructions comment dans cette
reconstruction nécessaire on associe
pleinement l'ensemble des habitants
comment on peut faire évoluer d'ailleurs
des équipements ou des conceptions
d'équipements donc en fonction notamment
des transitions de la transition
énergétique et écologique et aborder ça
avec des élus qui sont dans un pays en
guerre c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire c'est c'est une marque
encore une fois d'optimiste très
important donc nous avons donc cette
cette coopération qui se noue qui est
qui sont des coopérations à la fois
concrètes étroites moi je suis de ceux
qui pensent que bien sûr les grands
programmes sont importants naturellement
au niveau des États ça va être soit
notamment tout ce qui concerne
l'armement mais je pense que le contact
humain est absolument essentiel et c'est
la raison pour laquelle
cette initiative qui a été prise donc
pour une trentaine de villes donc en
France avec donc une trentaine de villes
ukrainiennes me paraît de voir être
développé en étant phase un peu
d'expérimentation voilà me paraît devoir
être développé je pense que je parle
Jean-Paul Guillaume et peut-être que la
délégation donc pourrait donc poursuivre
ce premier travail un peu expérimental
avec un dispositif pilote donc léger qui
pourrait soutenir donc l'accueil de
courte durée de ces petites délégations
d'élus deux trois élus à chaque fois et
de responsable locaux pour des missions
d'études ou généralistes ou thématiques
et donc je pense que cette ce
généralisation se développements de ce
type de ce type d'échange est absolument
essentiel à la construction donc de
partenariat solide qui ensuite pendant
toute la phase de reconstruction et elle
sera certainement extrêmement longue
pourra donc trouver toute son efficacité
voilà je voulais juste pour conclure
redire encore une fois mon génération
personnelle pour les élus Ukrainiens
pour l'ensemble du peuple crânien mais
aussi pour les mères ukrainiens et et
l'ensemble des élus
Ukrainiens qui font un travail
absolument considérable et qui sont
probablement un des éléments les plus
importants du ciment que qui unit dans
ces circonstances très difficiles donc
le peuple ukrainien merci cher Philippe
et je passe tout de suite la parole à
Christophe Rouillon cher Christophe
Rouillon au nom de l'Association des
maires de France qui s'est largement
engagé
sur ces sujets et bien sûr ta
responsabilité au titre de l'Europe dans
dans l'Association des maires de France
va nous éclairer
merci président
merci Philippe de ton de ton témoignage
et on travaille tout à fait la main de
la main avec la fccrre et on a la même
conviction aussi que ce jour
actuellement en Ukraine non seulement le
respect du droit international en disant
qu'on ne peut pas quel état souverain ne
peut pas être attaqué par un état voisin
sur le territoire européen mais
également aussi notre liberté et c'est
pourquoi nous en particulier nous
apportons notre soutien le plus fort
pour les mères et les élus en première
ligne qui combattent durement et qui
subissent aussi avec leurs populations
les bombardements
inhumain je dirais qui respecte aucune
des lois de la guerre et de ce point de
vue là notre soutien était dès le départ
et dans toutes les communes de France y
compris les plus petites comme comme la
mienne nous avons tendu la main nous
avons nous avons contribué pour ce qui
concerne ma ville lors de du sommet qui
a eu lieu à Kiev j'ai accepté la
proposition d'amer de la ligne de front
la ville de bakulive et nous sommes
jublés nous avons un partenariat et en
essayant de pouvoir le rendre le plus
concret possible parce que c'est
important aussi que les combattants
puissent avoir la sécurité que leurs
enfants vont pouvoir être accueillis
pendant les vacances dans le cas des
marquants et puis aussi que nous
pourrons accueillir les réfugiés que
nous pouvons aussi réfléchir à la façon
dont l'avenir va se créer en Ukraine
parce que le moral de la population
dépendra aussi de la perspective aussi
peut-être de rebâtir un nouveau pays en
restant optimiste parce que en voyant
les choses de loin on peut peut-être
parfois un peu pessimiste mais quand
j'entends le discours je me dis bon il y
a une perspective mais la guerre n'est
pas encore gagnée il faut absolument il
faut continuer à tenir bon je
m'exprimerai en tant que président du
groupe socialiste du Comité européen des
régions et membre également de la de la
tasse force Ukraine celle de cette
institution qui l'assemblée
représentative des élus locaux d'Europe
nos circuit institutionnel européen
et nous avons nous sommes engagés depuis
longtemps déjà à réfléchir à l'avenir de
l'Ukraine bien d'avoir la guerre et nous
avons renforcé notre action en
particulier en participant à plusieurs
conférences sur la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine
conférence sur la reconstruction Ukraine
qui a eu lieu dernièrement à Londres
l'alliance également européenne pour la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine et nous
sommes rendus à keV pour participer au
sommet à présent de du président ZZ kids
du secrétaire général de l'auteur le 25
mai dernier en réaffirmant notre volonté
au niveau européen de pouvoir peser sur
le discussion
au sein des astuces européennes pour
dégager un plan européen de
reconstruction également pour faire
valoir aussi l'importance que les
collectivités locales d'Europe soit
associé à ces travaux
d'Europe j'ai dire de l'Union européenne
et aussi de l'Ukraine de chaque être de
côté en sachant qu'il y a quand même
aussi des tensions c'est même du
gouvernement on a eu l'occasion à la
fois de rencontrer les représentants du
président ski également le maire de Kiev
et on voit bien que voilà ça bouillonne
aussi un peu de l'intérieur et je pense
qu'il y a vraiment une nécessité
d'associer de mettre en place vraiment
une gouvernance multiniveau et de
reconnaître le travail comme la fait le
Parlement européen dernièrement dans une
religion dans une résolution du 15 juin
dernier pour dire que les autorités
locales devaient être associées aux
travaux de reconstruction également qui
puisse aussi affirmer des principes de
transparence de responsabilité de lutte
contre la corruption et ce serait une
des conditions essentielles de
l'attribution des fonds européens de la
confiance aussi des citoyens
dans les gouvernements et puis aussi de
leur soutien au gouvernement pour
apporter des sommes qui vont être
considérables dans les années à venir
nous avons plaidé en particulier dans un
avis du
maire de Florence d'arrio Nardella pour
que il puisse y avoir une une aide
financière dans la durée pas simplement
d'urgence comme c'était le cas puisqu'il
y a eu quand même 18 millions de 18
milliards pardon qui ont été attribués
dans 30 milliards d'euros et 18
milliards d'euros donc ça fait 48
milliards d'euros mais un peu dans
l'urgence maintenant il faut il faut un
programme structurer une facilité un peu
sur le type de celle de la celle qui
était mise en place pendant la covid-19
ce qu'annonce la présidente de la
Commission européenne Ursule
avant-dernière c'est 33 milliards
d'euros de prêts 17 milliards d'euros de
subventions au total 50 milliards avec
une possibilité pour d'autres de pouvoir
abonder ce fond sachant que les besoins
pour l'Ukraine on a l'occasion d'en
parler avec pierrelbronn sont plutôt
l'estimés à 500 milliards c'est des
sommes de cette ordre là tout à l'heure
l'ambassadeur la dit très très nettement
il y a aussi des enjeux économiques et
financiers on fait de la philanthropie
on stabilise le continent européen mais
il faut aussi se rendre compte que c'est
un pays de 50 millions d'habitants c'est
pas rien qui est prêt et qui est prêt à
basculer qui la bascule pour en se
tournant vers l'Europe et où il y a bien
entendu des marchés de reconstruction
de pas se faire piquer par d'autres il
faut le dire clairement donc on a
vraiment intérêt aussi à aider et à
consolider les liens politiques par des
sites par des interventions économiques
avec l'Ukraine et aussi avec une demande
aussi qu'il puisse avoir des procédures
très strictes des procédures d'audites
de contrôle de suivi des
dépenses sur base de plans d'action qui
seront aussi
discutées sur le modèle de ce qui existe
déjà d'un politique de régional de
l'Union européenne avec une gouvernance
multiniveau avec un échange une
discussion entre l'Union européenne des
collectivités locales de France
également du crâne pour coller au mieux
aux besoins et ne pas avoir dispersion
défaut une mauvaise utilisation des
fonds et par la suite
des investissements qui correspondront
pas
un projet futur pour l'Ukraine de
développement de numérisation de
développement durable et de bonne
utilisation des défauts alors je
terminerai par rapport à la position du
Comité européen des régions nous sommes
favorables bien entendu un programme
pluriel avec si
des fonds qui soient garantis pour
l'Ukraine sur la base n'ont pas de fonds
qui seront piochés dans la politique de
cohésion parce qu'on va bien
qu'actuellement la marge de manœuvre
avec un budget qui sera peut-être pas
augmenté dans une révision ami parcours
du du plan de finance de du programme
plus annuel de financement de l'Union
européenne c'est le risque de piocher de
la 350 milliards de politique de
cohésion là ce serait
d'explorable par rapport à l'opinion
publique tu as été vers moi tu sais que
on a besoin de ces fonds européens dans
nos territoires ce serait vraiment une
très mauvaise idée de piocher dans ses
fonds en sachant c'est vrai qu'au niveau
européen ce sont pas les fonds les plus
médiatiques et je vois bien une certaine
peut-être un certain portion durcir la
Vendée à la hyène ou d'autres de dire
tiens ils sont pas trop ces fonds ne
sont pas trop connus ils sont souvent
Gladiator on va prendre ses fonds on va
les donner l'Ukraine ça évitera de
négocier avec les états une augmentation
du budget
voilà donc nous ce que l'on souhaite
c'est qu'il y a effectivement peut-être
un endettement commun de l'Union
européenne sur le modèle ce qui était
fait pour la facilité pour la relance
après le la covid et que l'on puisse
financer à long terme
c'est politique avec
un renforcement de la démocratie locale
une gouvernance à plusieurs niveaux
et puis aussi comme je viens de le dire
une répartition des fonds sur le modèle
de la méthodologie des politiques
régionales de l'Union européenne nous
aurons différentes étapes prochainement
de suivi au niveau de du Comité européen
des régions au niveau européen on aura
un sommet du groupe de travail Ukraine
qui aura lieu normalement le 16 octobre
à le vive et nous passons aussi nous
aurons un atelier lors de la Semaine
européenne des villes et des régions et
on va continuer à travailler également
avec nos partenaires parce qu'il y a
allemand qui voilà qui ont mis en place
des groupes de travail en sont pour
l'Europe solidarité reconstruction
perspective d'avenir et une réunion qui
aura lieu à la psych donc voilà je pense
que c'est vraiment très important qu'on
puisse agir sur le terme et que on peut
aussi collectivement faire pression
auprès de nos gouvernements
avant les élections européennes qui vont
arriver l'année prochaine pour avoir
vraiment un plan de long terme un plan
garanti qui nous assure une bonne
utilisation des fonds et d'utilisation
de cette facilité pour la relancer et la
croissance dès que la guerre sera fini
j'espère le plus rapidement possible
merci merci Christophe oui sur les fonds
c'est un vrai sujet justement en phase
de renégociation du cadre financier
pluriel il y a il y a aussi quelques
questions qui se posent
sur les différents postes budgétaires et
sur la contribution des états c'est
c'est un sujet qu'on construit très prêt
à la commission des affaires européennes
du Sénat Monsieur Bertrand marié
c'est à vous maintenant pour nous donner
les aspects peut-être plus économique au
titre du commerce et de l'industrie dans
la relation franco-ukrainienne
merci Monsieur mesdames les élus bonjour
monsieur mesdames
Bertrand barrier je suis en effet le
président de la Chambre de commerce
franco-ukrainienne je vais apporter
peut-être aujourd'hui un éclairage un
petit peu différent de ceux qui ont été
apportés jusqu'à présent c'est un
éclairage plus économique sur la
présence des sociétés françaises en
Ukraine et sur nos actions
avant la guerre et depuis la guerre
la Chambre de commerce Franco
ukrainienne existe depuis 1994
on regroupe aujourd'hui
170 entreprises françaises présentes en
Ukraine on représente
plus de 95% de la présence française en
Ukraine
la France n'est peut-être pas le premier
employeur en Ukraine enfin n'est pas le
premier investisseur en Ukraine mais on
est le premier invest le premier
employeur étranger en
Ukraine
on est présent on a la chance d'être
présent
dans tous les secteurs d'activité on est
il faut savoir que il y a en Ukraine
seul 5 banques étrangères sont présentes
sur le marché et deux d'entre elles sont
françaises donc avec la BNP le Crédit
Agricole on est très présent dans le
domaine pharmaceutique avec des grands
groupes tels que Sanofi Servier Biocodex
avec une présence importante sur le pays
évidemment dans le domaine
agroalimentaire qui est un des points
forts de l'Ukraine la France est très
bien représentée avec des grands groupes
tels que belle bon grain Danone Lactalis
qui ont chacun des usines de production
en Ukraine
le domaine Haïti également très bien
représenté et évidemment tout le domaine
de la distribution avec les groupes aux
champs Décathlon Leroy Merlin
toute la cosmétique avec de Leroy Merlin
aux produits aux produits de luxe donc
une très belle présence française en
Ukraine une présence
importante
et également quelques années avant le
début du conflit le développement du
renforcement d'une relation au niveau
gouvernemental entre la France et
l'Ukraine très importante avec des
grands projets intergouvernementaux ou
la France avait financé en bilatérale
des grands contrats tels que
Airbus sur la vente d'hélicoptère
océans sur la la vente de bateaux et des
discussions concernant des locomotives
avec Alstom il y avait également deux
projets avec les municipalités très
importants avec
la municipalité de Mario Paul dont on a
des parlé aujourd'hui avec un un projet
d'assainissement de l'eau c'était
financé et un projet sur Kiev également
en
approvisionnement en eau
donc une présence importante en Ukraine
ce qui est important peut-être de
souligner c'est que la
aucune des sociétés présentes avant la
guerre n'a quitté territoire ukrainien
depuis la guerre les entreprises ont
évidemment toutes subis un choc
important et en particulier leurs
salariés depuis le début du conflit avec
selon la présence soit en région soit
Kiev soit dans l'est du pays soit à
l'Ouest du pays selon leurs activités
évidemment un impact différent
un impact qui peut aller de la
destruction de bâtiments à la saisie de
de mine ou de de d'usine dans les
régions occupées avec une mobilisation
importante des entreprises françaises
pour
relocaliser leurs salariés leur assurer
la sécurité et logement pas nécessaire
pour continuer les activités
aujourd'hui un mot par rapport à
l'activité il est important de souligner
que les entreprises françaises ont une
activité à peu près à hauteur de 70% de
chiffre d'affaires de ce qu'elle
réalisait avant la guerre donc une ça
c'est plutôt une bonne surprise et c'est
un point très important à souligné c'est
que les entreprises françaises
continuent leur activité ont une bonne
activité et sont évidemment
un des piliers de la reconstruction et
de la résistance économique d'un pays
aujourd'hui puisque c'est important
d'assurer la survie économique pour la
population ukrainienne donc ça c'est ça
c'est c'est un point important
[Musique]
maintenant par rapport aux activités de
la de la Chambre de commerce
nous on est
on joue un rôle plein et entier dans
toute l'équipe dans tout ce qu'on
appelle la team France à savoir tout le
rôle de d'information de coordination
des différents efforts qui vont être
faits la reconstruction c'est un
chantier énorme il y a deux questions
qui se posent évidemment c'est quel
financement et ensuite quel pour la
réalisation de quel projet donc
aujourd'hui nous au sein de la Chambre
de commerce on fait des webinaires avec
les principaux interlocuteurs Ukrainiens
les principaux acteurs qui seront en
charge de la reconstruction pour
comprendre un quels sont les besoins
deux quels sont les acteurs et ensuite
du côté français pour identifier et bien
les capacités les entreprises qui seront
évidemment le plus à même à jouer un
rôle important dans la reconstruction
donc
on organise on est également en contact
et on a une connaissance du fait du
maillage on est vraiment une
connaissance terrain puisque les
entreprises françaises sont présentes
dans
toutes les grandes villes évidemment
mais également dans beaucoup des plus
petites villes
ukrainiennes si on vous prenait
l'exemple des agences bancaires la BNP à
400 agences bancaire ils sont présents
donc dans 400 vies au moins et pareil
pour le
pareil pour le Crédit Agricole donc il y
a une grosse connaissance du tissu et
économique il y a une grande
connaissance du tissu
municipal et régional et donc on est on
organise également
alors à l'époque on organisait des
déplacements en région dans les dans les
municipalités
aujourd'hui c'est différent on travaille
plus sur des échanges qui sont des
présentations qui sont faites par
webinaire avec avec les membres et les
personnes intéressées
voilà donc c'est ça aujourd'hui le rôle
de la Chambre de commerce avec encore
une fois
un rôle essentiellement de coordination
avec l'ensemble des autres acteurs de la
team France qui sont business France la
mission économique l'ambassade de France
en Ukraine voilà merci
merci
vous n'avez pas dépassé votre temps et
c'est bien ça me permet peut-être de
vous poser une petite question
intermédiaire j'évoquais avec Jean-yves
Lecomte la question du déplacement des
entreprises sur le territoire ukrainien
et des problèmes d'assurance liés aux
personnes et aux risques qui peuvent
être engendrés vous pouvez nous dire 30
secondes qu'il en est alors c'est c'est
en effet un des grands points puisque
aujourd'hui du fait de la jurisprudence
Karachi les groupes ne peuvent pas sans
assurance demander à leur dirigeants
d'aller en Ukraine donc relativement peu
de déplacement il faut savoir quand même
que les entreprises moi autour de moi
tous les tous les dirigeants français
qui
dirigent des entreprises françaises vont
et se rendre en Ukraine ils ont trouvé
des moyens d'assurance c'est compliqué à
mettre en place puisque ça veut dire
beaucoup de négociations individuelles
nous au niveau de la Chambre de Commerce
et avec les autres chambres de commerce
nationale que ce soit les Allemands les
Américains ont on milite et on essaye de
pousser une solution pour pour que pour
trouver une société une compagnie
d'assurance qui serait prêt à prendre le
risque pour l'ensemble des expatriés qui
doivent se rendre ou des gens qui
doivent se rendre en déplacement à
l'Ukraine avec une procédure simplifiée
qui permettrait évidemment de se rendre
plus facilement bon il y a la difficulté
du temps de trajet puisque aujourd'hui
le minimum d'un temps de trajet c'est 24
heures mais tout du moins de pouvoir s'y
rendre avec une assurance
ça serait en effet c'est quelque chose
qui dont on a besoin et qui qui serait
la première pierre de l'édifice pour la
reconstruction si on veut que ça puisse
avancer rapidement merci
merci
bien on va continuer avec nos experts en
économie on va passer la parole à Madame
Laurence de toucher qui est directrice
de la zone Europe centrale et orientale
chez business France à vous madame merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président bonjour à
toutes et à tous donc je suis Laurence
de toucher moi je suis basée non pas en
Ukraine mais à Varsovie puisque je suis
responsable pour business France des
bureaux de la zone Europe centrale et
orientale et donc de l'Ukraine qui est
dans ma circonscription si je peux dire
ainsi nous avons quatre bureaux dans
cette zone là à Varsovie à Prague à
Bucarest et à Kiev toujours nous avons
effectivement toujours un bureau à Kiev
qui n'a jamais fermé depuis le début de
la guerre alors avant la guerre nous
l'avions six personnes a maintenant nous
n'avons plus que trois collaboratrices
qui sont trois collaboratrices
ukrainiennes extrêmement expérimentés
certaines depuis plus de 15 à 20 ans
chez nous qui connaissent très très bien
les secteurs de l'économie
ukrainienne et la la semaine dernière
nous avons notre directeur de du bureau
qui est qui a pris ses fonctions à Kiev
donc il y a un directeur business France
expatrié donc ça c'est un succès pour
nous d'avoir réussi à le nommer là-bas
et à le faire partir et donc arriver et
il connaît très bien du crâne puisqu'il
était donc il travaillait pour une
entreprise semencier français massite
pendant deux nombreuses années et donc à
tout à fait implanté localement donc il
va pouvoir allier la connaissance de
fonctionnement d'une entreprise
française une filiale française la
connaissance
ukrainienne donc voilà on a un
dispositif avec quatre personnes qui est
totalement opérationnel alors évidemment
on renseigne les entreprises le coeur de
métier de business France c'est de
d'accompagner de renseigner et
d'accompagner les PME et ETI françaises
en particulier à l'export donc voilà en
complémentarité par rapport à ce que
fait la chambre avec les entreprises
déjà bien bien implantées comme il
l'expliquait alors aujourd'hui on va pas
dire qu'on accompagne tous les jours des
entreprises sur le marché ukrainien bien
sûr pour les raisons qu'on évoquait déjà
né il y a un grand besoin de
d'information donc on participe à pas
mal de webinaires d'informations on
rédige une de lettre de veille mensuelle
avec des informations économiques pour
donner l'information sur la
reconstruction du crâne on va en parler
mais aussi sur le fait qu'une partie de
l'économie ukrainienne continue à
fonctionner parce que les trains
continuent à rouler parce que les gens
continuent à consommer et à manger parce
que les agroaldings continuent à
fonctionner ont besoin d'équipements
donc ça il faut pas du tout l'occulter
quand on parle de l'Ukraine et de la
reconstruction parce qu'il y a des
choses à faire aujourd'hui même
indépendamment de la construction donc
notre activité elle tourne autour de
cela
ce qui a été aussi il y a un gros moteur
de notre activité depuis le début de
l'année c'est le forum rebile du crime
on en parlait tout à l'heure donc au
mois de février les organisateurs de
salon Ukrainiens expo 21 ont décidé de
faire un salon conférence et un salon
non pas Kiev pour des raisons de
sécurité mais à Varsovie donc un grand
salon pour les entreprises étrangères et
donc nous avons organisé un pavillon
France
autour d'une douzaine d'entreprises
françaises déjà sur les thématiques de
la reconstruction et donc ce salon a eu
tellement de succès que les
organisateurs font une deuxième édition
dès novembre à mi-novembre et là nous
avons décidé de pouvoir doubler notre
présence donc on a déjà plus d'une
vingtaine d'inscrits la Chambre de
commerce sera partenaire sur notre
pavillon d'ailleurs et donc à l'occasion
de ce salon la particularité c'était que
les Ukrainiens avaient souhaité que ce
soit un salon B2i donc avec des
collectivités territoriales ukrainiennes
qui viendraient exposer leurs besoins
lors d'un marathon des collectivités et
qui viendrait aussi voir les solutions
de proposer par les entreprises
étrangères et donc ce sera la même
formule au mois de novembre donc c'est
vrai qu'on a vu beaucoup de
collectivités territoriales
ukrainiennes à cette occasion qui ont
rencontré nos entreprises l'ambassadeur
de France Frédéric billet et les avait
invités aussi à la Résidence il y a eu
des moments de networking et des changes
très intéressants avec le maire de
nicolaief des personnes de Kerson tiers
niggy végétomie donc il y avait 24
collectivité territoriale représentée et
je pense qu'il y en aura encore plus en
novembre donc un moment intéressant qui
peut être pour les entreprises mais
peut-être aussi pour des collectivités
territoriales françaises parce que là
seront rassemblés à pas mal de
collectivités
ukrainiennes aussi et ça peut ça peut
créer des liens donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui a qui a vraiment démarré
redémarrer notre activité en particulier
sur la reconstruction on a vu deux types
d'entreprises des entreprises déjà assez
aguerris sur le marché ukrainien et donc
qui souhaitait continuer à y travailler
et à participer à la reconstruction ou
alors des entreprises qui connaissaient
pas du tout l'Ukraine mais qui avait
l'habitude de marcher en crise de pays
en crise en guerre et qui du coup avait
des spécificités une offre spécifique à
faire valoir un peu ces deux types
d'entreprises qui ont besoin et c'est là
qu'on va intervenir qui ont besoin d'un
décryptage pour savoir quels vont être
les dos en ordre comment se retrouver
est-ce que c'est la municipalité
loblaste est-ce que c'est l'entreprise
privée à qui elle donne à faire donc
voilà il y a un besoin de décryptage et
c'est ça qu'on va on va s'attacher à
faire et puis après il y a des besoins
bien sûr de sécurisation dont on a déjà
parlé mais ça c'est pas c'est pas notre
coeur de métier à nous bien sûr voilà
donc ce qui nous a donné ce qui nous
donne l'idée qu'il faut travailler dans
la durée avec ces entreprises qui
souhaiteraient pouvoir participer à la
reconstruction de l'Ukraine et proposer
leurs solutions parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de préparations à faire pour celles qui
connaissent pas ce marché là beaucoup
d'accompagnement voilà donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on souhaiterait
travailler et voir peut-être travailler
avec des collectivités territoriales
aussi pour leurs entreprises
on peut les accompagner dans la durée
sur le marché ukrainien pour participer
à la reconstruction d'Ukraine voilà donc
en gros notre cœur de métier donc on est
tout à fait disposé et on l'a déjà fait
à la demande à intervenir lors de
webinaire ou de réunion pour telle ou
tel région française pour voilà apporter
les désinformations qu'on a du terrain
et puis voir comment on pourrait aider
les entreprises françaises on travaille
en tant que membre fondateur de la team
France donc avec les CCI en région voilà
donc on est tout à fait ouvert à pouvoir
apporter ce type ce type d'information
sachant que voilà ou alors accompagné
physiquement mais comme on le disait
déjà ça peut être un petit peu plus
difficile voilà donc à long terme l'idée
ça serait de pouvoir créer des
programmes d'accompagnement un petit
booster d'entreprise enfin booster c'est
un terme qu'on utilise un petit peu
généralement pour beaucoup de choses
mais en fait voilà pouvoir proposer des
briques d'accompagnement aux entreprises
pour vraiment les prendre par la main
pour celles qui auraient besoin qu'on
les prenne par la main sur voilà sur un
marché qui est assez complexité et à
pouvoir trouver les bons partenaires
voilà je pense que j'ai fait à peu près
le tour de ce qu'on a fait et de ce
qu'on recommence à faire en tous les cas
avec une équipe encore une fois très
motivée et en ordre de marche et en
partenariat au sein de cette team France
Export avec la Chambre de commerce
française en Ukraine
merci beaucoup Madame la Directrice
alors on va aller maintenant en visio du
côté de l'Ukraine et on va retrouver
Ivan Fedorov bonjour Ivan qui est au
téléphone c'est pas si nous entend
bonjour Ivan très heureux de vous revoir
puisque vous étiez venu au Sénat
l'invitation du président Larcher avec
une délégation de députés ukrainienne on
vous avait entendu à l'époque avec
beaucoup d'émotion parce que vous avez
vous sortiez d'une épreuve très très
difficile au regard de l'invasion et
voilà je vois que vous portez bien ça ça
fait plaisir de vous voir et que vous
êtes aussi vous plein d'espoir sur la
sur la reconstruction future donc c'est
à vous
de prendre la parole je vous remercie de
la possibilité de représenter les
territoires temporairement occupés du
sud de notre pays je suis ravie de
participer à un format aussi important
qui souligne encore une fois l'aide
exceptionnelle que la France apporte
aujourd'hui à l'Ukraine au nom des
habitants du Sud
occupé de l'Ukraine qui vit aujourd'hui
dans la plus grande prison d'Europe qui
sont les premiers à être intéressés dans
la restauration de l'Ukraine le plus
rapide possible la plus grande aide pour
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui le plus urgent
c'est les armements pour nos militaires
je voudrais vous remercier bien
évidemment pour le fait que des
centaines de milliers d'ukrainien qui
ont perdu leur logement qui fuit la
guerre vous les avez accueillis qu'ils
ont trouvé refuge en France je vous
remercie de votre position inébranlable
dans le soutien de l'Ukraine dans cette
guerre à l'encontre de la Russie et je
vous remercie personnellement
au président français Monsieur Emmanuel
Macron pour sa participation d'un direct
d'un mâle libération de la captivité qui
l'emprisement qui a été organisé par les
services secrets russes car c'est grâce
aux efforts du Président français que je
peux être présent ici et tout ce que
fait votre état en direction de
l'Ukraine nous rapproche de notre
victoire commune je veux je peux être
également l'avocat de les territoires
d'Azov et qui sont en pour moi occupés
de ma ville natale de melithopole et
vous expliquer pourquoi sans la
décoccupation ils sont le développement
constant de cette région la victoire de
l'Ukraine sera impossible et ce qui
menacerait la sécurité du monde entier
les régions
est une région clé pour le développement
de l'Ukraine c'est le centre logistique
de l'Est de l'Europe c'est le croisement
de voies ferrées et de routes de
portance européenne la région d'azoffre
a des conditions nécessaires pour
devenir un grand centre industriel de
leur ne prenne et de l'Est de l'Europe
la région d'azove a une accès vers la
zone vers la mer d'Azov ce qui permet de
créer une zone de récréation une zone de
tourisme et il y a un port à perdience
qui permet de créer un noeud de
transport dans la région cette région
est très favorable au développement de
des solutions écologiques c'est aussi
une sorte d'entrée pour notre Crimée
occupé aujourd'hui la zone est la place
forte de la frontière entre le monde
civilisé démocratique et le pays
totalitaire et agresseur le
la région d'Azov est un couloir entre la
Crimée temporairement occupée c'est pas
pour rien que les
occupants russes tient à tenir ce
couloir terrestre en direction de la
Crimée mais ce qui n'est pas moins
important c'est que nous avons d'autres
projets pour cette région la
restauration de la région d'Azov après
l'occupation est une priorité je suis
certain que grâce à nos armées et notre
armée héroïque et l'aide de la
communauté nationale la région d'azo
sera libérée et après sa libération
cette région devrait faire partie des
priorités du développement économique et
stratégique de notre pays car seul cette
région
prospère pourra
contre agir à au développement du monde
russe que la Russie la France connaît
parfaitement ce que veut dire la
propagande et comment elle fonctionne
notre objectif commun et d'y mettre fin
l'équipe de monopole notre équipe
aujourd'hui pour demain nous déployons
tous nos efforts pour soutenir de
militaires nous nous concentrons sur la
restauration et le renouvellement de
cette région immédiatement après sa
déoccupation mais little est a été une
des premières régions à élaborer un
programme de préoccupations qui prévoit
trois mesures que vous voyez devant vous
le premier pas c'est la restauration
urgente de la structure critique afin de
permettre le fonctionnement de
territoire non comprenant que la
libération de la ville conduira à la
destruction de la ville car les
occupants en se retirant vont emporter
tout ce qu'il y a de la valeur nous nous
préparons donc à la restauration dès
maintenant nous étudions en détail
l'expérience des personnes préoccuper et
de la région de fatigue qui a été
occupée nous sommes prêts à tous ces
noms nous préparons déjà l'équipe de
restauration nous avons près de 2000
personnes spécialistes différentes
domaines
personne qui est prête à simplifier dans
la restauration de notre rêve nous
accumulons et nos collectons les choses
de première nécessité le générateurs les
équipements les objets de première
nécessité nous avons commencé à
restaurer le parc communal de transport
en municipal qui sera nécessaire
deuxième mesure très importante ce sont
les gens les gens et la valeur
principale de notre région la
collaboration à meltopol est très faible
malgré un an et demi d'occupation nos
habitants attendent la libération et la
rapproche le plus vite de toute leur
force ce qui reste sont restés
imperméables à la propagande russe et
reste de véritable patriote de notre
pays ceux qui ont quitté la région sont
devenus les ambassadeurs de notre ville
dans différents pays de l'Union
européenne mais l'occupation durable
modifier le lieu d'habitation de nos
gens et différentes facteurs ne peuvent
pas rester sans influence nous avons
trois objectifs le premier objectif est
d'assurer la demande à la soif de la
justice tous les collaborateurs doivent
être punis et ceux qui sont restés
fidèles à l'Ukraine dans l'occupation
puisse ressentir donc la gratification
le retour de tous ceux qui ont dû
quitter la région et les réunir autour
de l'objectif principal le développement
et la prospérité de la région pour
l'atteindre nos attribuons une
importance particulière à l'éducation
car l'éducation est un des facteurs clés
de notre état l'unité nationale la
préparation des experts tout cela est
promu dans les établissements
d'éducation et le troisième mesure c'est
le développement une stratégie de
développement
perspective c'est la préparation de
stratégies de développement où nous
souhaitons impliquer nos impliquons déjà
les spécialistes internationaux en
prenant compte de notre expérience et de
leur expérience nous pouvons déjà
utiliser les axes de développement les
plus importants et prometteur c'est tout
d'abord le secteur agraire la région
d'Azov c'est plus de 2 millions
d'hectares de
terre qui permet de de cultiver
différents types de de produits
malheureusement après l'explosion du
barrage nous avons un autre problème qui
apparaît c'est l'absence de d'arrosage
de de nos terres qui s'assèchent et donc
il ne faut trouver d'autres moyens les
énergies vertes avant cette agression
nous avons déjà étudié les possibilités
de d'énergie renouvelables nous avions
un centrale thermique de biogaz en
méthane l'énergie du vent etc le
développement du potentiel de récréation
la restauration de cette zone et de sa
restauration est un objectif important
et nous devons
être attention au développement du
tourisme à la protection de
l'environnement et nous allons faire
bien évidemment la zone de
réhabilitation pour tous nos militaires
qui aujourd'hui défendent notre état le
développement de ces trois axes est
logique et organiques avec le
développement de la structure
l'infrastructure sociale de la région
nous avons déjà l'expérience
d'implication des institutions et leur
restauration des établissements
éducatifs sociaux et médicaux nous
utilisons également tout ce potentiel
pour la dégustation également et
seulement grâce à la combinaison de ces
facteurs que nous pourrons construire la
région d'azo économiquement fiable et
attractive mais soyons réalistes nous ne
pourrons pas y arriver
nous pourrons le faire uniquement en
coopération avec nos partenaires
internationaux c'est pourquoi nous avons
besoin de votre aide aussi bien à
l'étape de création de la stratégie de
développement de la région qu'au stade
de sa réalisation et ce qui sera très
important et précieux pour nous c'est
l'aide des municipalités d'égal à égal
car nous avons déjà vous avez déjà le
développement
à succès de vos régions partager avec
nous cette expérience réunissons nos
efforts au nom de l'avenir ce qui nous
donnera la possibilité unique de créer
et de construire un pays qui sera le
gage de la future forte je vous remercie
de votre attention
merci chérie vannes alors avant de
passer la parole à la salle je voudrais
savoir si nos amis Ukrainiens veulent
réagir et on me dit que le maire adjoint
d'erpine monsieur negrescha souhaiterait
souhaiterait réagir
merci de cette possibilité je remercie
tout d'abord la France et les Français
de
d'aider l'Ukraine
de l'aider à gagner l'agression contre
l'agression russe le cannique dans cette
guerre et je voudrais remercier
également les organisateurs françaises
qui nous apportent leur aide et
s'implique dans la restauration de notre
ville la ville d'urpigne a été détruite
à 70% la ville de région de cueille et
aujourd'hui est en train de se restaurer
afin d'offrir la possibilité à nos
habitants de revenir dans leur maison
la ville d'urpigne le Président français
est venu dans notre ville en juin de
l'année dernière et nous avons également
reçu le président de l'Association des
Maires le France le maire de ma ville de
Cannes sur snap il a également vu de ses
propres yeux les conséquences
destruction de la ville aujourd'hui nous
sommes très aidés par Leroy Merlin la
société française
qui est notre aide à restaurer les
immeubles
et qui travaille de manière efficace
pour aider les habitants de ces
maisons
en passant outre la municipalité pour
apporter directement les matériaux de
construction et l'aide aux habitants
directement dans leur restauration la
ville aujourd'hui est renouvelée à 20%
c'est 20% ce sont les communication et
les infrastructures stratégiques iques
et examen les infrastructures sociales
les écoles les crèches grâce au fond
internationaux la les gouvernements les
fonds nous avons été aidés dans la
restauration des écoles des crèches et
des infrastructures communales
pourquoi j'évoque tout ceci
c'est parce que nous bénéficions
aujourd'hui des d'ores et déjà
les des partenaires internationaux
pour
donc diriger et des fonds dirigés
et la ville d'irpine est un excellent
exemple comment dans les villes
déoccupées dans les villes libérées les
projets d'aide internationale peuvent
être réalisés dans des délais très
courts
parce que
c'est le choix de l'opérateur de projet
c'est les fonds les fonds les
contributeurs qui gèrent leurs projets
ils choisissent
quel site restaurer rénové
quelle entreprise prendre en local pour
pour opérer le projet
les autorités locales ne s'engère pas et
non pas de droit de regard dans ses
projets
et je voudrais dire que pendant la
résistance je voudrais souligner notre
statut de la ville Hérault 30 jours
notre ville a été dans l'occupation dans
un combat le maire de la ville monsieur
arkoucha
personnellement dirigé la défense
territoriale de la ville
étant donné que nous sommes
géographiquement très très près de
cuivre à 7 km
c'était vraiment une distance critique
donc c'est pour ça que c'était très
important de tenir ce dernier
ces dernières lignes de défense avant la
capitale et nous nous félicitons de la
marche de train de
reconstruction de notre ville et nous
sommes très connaissant à tous les
partenaires qui nous aident déjà ils
appellent tous ceux qui ne l'ont pas
encore
commencé
cette aide à le faire à le faire parce
que nous avons tant besoin de
reconstruire nos villes comme d'autres
villes ukrainiennes libérées
j'ai entendu que vous avez participé à
la conférence à Varsovie build
Ukraine
nous allons aussi participer à cette
conférence
et donc nous sommes tout à fait ouvert à
la coopération avec les villes
françaises avec les collectivités
territoriales c'est tellement simple
d'établir les relations directement
entre les collectivités et encore une
fois permettez-moi de remercier très
chaleureusement tous les français pour
ce pour tout ce qui est fait pour nous
aider pour qu'on nous puissions arrêter
cette agression de Fédération de Russie
merci
lui la parole et dont
je précise qu'un partenariat était
engagé avec la ville de Reims c'est à
vous Monsieur le Maire
bonjour En chers collègues
je souscris entièrement à ce qui était
dit par les personnes qui ont parlé avec
moi pour remercier très chaleureusement
la nation française
pour leur aide à l'Ukraine
alors je voulais dire que la réforme de
décentralisation qui était commencé
encore avant la guerre en Ukraine
c'était une des trois plus grandes
réformes réalisées sur la dernière
décennie et cette réforme a joué un rôle
crucial maintenant dans la problématique
de guerre pour gérer les problématiques
de personnes déplacées
et pour d'autres problématiques notre
ville se trouve à 70 km de la frontière
c'était une ville qui est la plus l'une
des premières touchées par les frappes
ennemis le 24 février dans la nuit nous
nous sommes retrouvés dans un
cerclement partiel
nous avons subi des tirs d'artillerie et
des bombardements aériens et
selon les estimations de l'école et
d'économie et de cuivre la ville a
besoin maintenant 4
milliards 200 millions pour reconstruire
tout ce qui a été détruit par ces
bombardements par ces destructions
mais nous avons par le temps d'attendre
la fin de la guerre nous avons déjà
commencé la reconstruction ici avant la
guerre dans notre ville il y avait 200
000 habitants dans la guerre avant la
Guerre de cent mille maintenant il y a
seulement 70
c'était très important dès lors de
commencer la reconstruction très vite
pour donner un signal que notre ville
est vivante est pour vous tous les
forces vives qui puissent revenir
peuvent retourner et il y a déjà une
grande partie qui sont retenées et même
si encore entre 20 et 30
000 de nos ressortissants se trouvent
donc ailleurs dans d'autres villes mais
nous lutons nous luttons quotidiennement
pour que il puisse tous les tous nos
citoyens de la ville puissent revenir
dans la Versailles d'origine
nous avons vraiment très beaucoup très
nous sommes très déterminés pour avoir
des partenariats avec des villes pour
les partenaires publics privés parce que
nous avons besoin de technologie et nous
avons besoin de confiance et d'ailleurs
la ville nous allons la recons dans un
esprit de confiance entre les citoyens
nous voulons avoir une vision commune
comment la reconstruire et surtout est
reconstruire pour réaffirmer les valeurs
de la liberté et de la démocratie et les
valeurs qui nous sont si chères et notre
ville se trouve au coeur de l'Europe et
nous avons prouvé que nous appartenons
pleinement à la famille européenne que
nous sommes vraiment au cœur de l'Europe
et nous souhaitons vraiment
atteindre le point de notre de nos
retours dans ces institutions
démocratiques et quand je voudrais
recourir
le maire de Reims qui est venu nous voir
il a dit que Reims quand il a il était
très très détruit après le deuxième
guerre mondiale
et beaucoup de partenaires
internationaux sont venus à l'aide à la
ville de Reims parce que toute seule
j'étais incapable de faire face à
l'ampleur de destruction et maintenant
il a une responsabilité de particulière
pour aider la ville comme tchernaki
parce que il s'est rendu sur place et il
a vu l'ampleur de destruction
et nous nous souhaitons vraiment avoir
des relations de confiance et de
transparence avec nos partenaires
c'est pour ça quand nous avons des
partenaires internationaux nous dégrons
tout tout le projet nous ne donc sans
aucun droit de regard c'est les
partenaires internationaux qui eux-mêmes
choisissent les fonds des appels
d'offres choisissent donc les
partenaires locaux et c'est très
important
d'avoir cette confiance et il est très
important aussi
que la France réfléchisse à un mécanisme
pérenne
d'assurance
d'assurance pour les sociétés pour les
pour les entreprises et aussi pour les
collaborateurs parce que c'est très
important de d'avoir cette assurance
risque pour que les investisseurs
puissent venir plus rapidement je
soulève cette problématique
régulièrement et je voudrais que vous
ça avance et aussi je voudrais attirer
votre attention que dans le cadre de la
loi de décentralisation les
collectivités territoriales ukrainiennes
ont des très larges pouvoirs et ils ont
un possibilité de définir leur projet
parce qu'ils connaissent bien leur
priorité ils ont la proximité des
citoyens et donc c'est très important
que la voix de l'autonomie locale
ukrainienne puisse être entendu lorsque
les projets de reconstruction sont
débattus grandes échelle les grands
projets de restriction de l'Ukraine nous
vous remercions pour votre soutien merci
et nous allons vaincre merci beaucoup de
vos témoignages
[Applaudissements]
intéressants bien sûr mes poignants
allez je prends deux questions dans la
salle parce que je voudrais que Madame
Gatel notre égérie collectivité locale
puisse puisse s'exprimer pour conclure
allez
la première est toujours difficile à
poser on passe à la deuxième
vous savez tout vous n'osez pas
Nadia
j'ai introduit les débats juste avant
ton arrivée
non non mais je voudrais surtout pas
qu'appareil faut profiter de la présence
de nos invités
comment comment enfin c'est une question
assez générale comment comment va la
jeunesse en Ukraine donc c'est de pas
simple mais comment vit-elle la guerre
comment les collectivités peuvent
l'aider je crois que j'ai entendu parler
de camp de vacances
voilà donc si vous pouvez vous pouviez
apporter quelques éléments sur la
jeunesse ukrainienne qui est
également la jeunesse européenne donc ça
nous concerne et je pense que nous on
peut être solidaire aussi avec elle
merci beaucoup alors c'est Philippe
c'est Philippe qui qui s'est exprimé
Philippe on laisse peut-être répondre
nos interlocuteurs craignent qui qui
vivent avec eux qui veut répondre pour
cette question si vous l'avez entendu
sur finalement comment vit la jeunesse
la jeunesse ukrainienne aujourd'hui dans
ce contexte
je peux et si je peux répondre je peux
répondre
comment la jeunesse ukrainienne vit et
la guerre sur l'exemple de ma vie
je peux dire que maintenant tous les
villes
avec lesquelles nous sommes jumelés nous
avons des accords déjà que elle est
jeune de notre ville partiront en camp
d'été en camp de vacances et ça ce
serait très précieux pour eux ne
serait-ce que avoir quelques semaines de
déchasse décharger mentalement de ne
plus penser à la guerre
c'est une aide très précieuse
pour la santé mentale des jeunes nous
avons cinq villes jumelles
au Portugal une ville en Géorgie une
ville
en Allemagne Burga et donc ces villes
ont déjà reçu
30 et des groupes de 30 40 jeunes
ukrainiens et dans les camps d'été
encore des jeunes et surtout ce sont des
villes et qui sont souvent au bord de la
mer donc pour nos enfants c'est un
vraiment une grande chance une privilège
mais s'opposer un obstacle financier
et je voulais savoir si du point de vue
de l'État il y avait peut-être un moyen
de de les communes en particulier
communes les plus pauvres c'est le coup
moyen et en ce moment tout le monde est
pauvre
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait être aidé
pour acheminer les enfants depuis la
frontière
ukrainienne jusque dans nos territoires
ce qu'il y a par le biais peut-être de
fond du ministère ce qui est pas une
possibilité de têtes de dégager un peu
de crédit moi je sais ce qui bloque dans
ma ville on est prêt à tout gérer sur
place par contre le problème du
transport est très coûteux et voilà
c'est un obstacle par rapport à nos
équipes municipales aux efforts qu'on
demande à la population est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose qui peut-être qui serait
pris au niveau de l'État
l'ambassadeur on a on va prendre
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur après on a une
question encore une prise de parole
ukrainienne qu'ils ont ils demandent la
parole au fur et à mesure sur la vision
merci beaucoup je crois qu'il ne sera
pas possible d'étudier au cas par cas
collectivités territoriales françaises
par collectivité territoriales
françaises
je crois que même si on mobilisait tous
les services du ministère de la Jeunesse
et des Sports à cette fin là on y
arriverait pas puisqu'il y a des
obstacles
financiers mais pas que en revanche il y
a peut-être la place là pour une
initiative d'une association de
collectivité territoriale et
l'aide qui pourrait être dégagée serait
mobilisé par le ministère des Affaires
étrangères mais au bénéfice de cette
association qui aurait ensuite à sa
charge de répartir l'aide et d'être au
plus près des collectivités
territoriales nous-mêmes nous pourrons
pas gérer
je ne sais pas combien de connectivité
des territoriales françaises seraient
concernés on ne pourrait pas avoir une
démarche contractuelle avec chaque
collectivité
merci bien
votre proposition président l'isnard
mais à condition qu'on nous dise un peu
de quel volume on peut bénéficier pour
voir comment une fois les micros éteints
mais je suis là tout l'été juillet août
donc je peux signer à tout moment pour
permettre de jeunes Ukrainiens de venir
en vacances en français bien je pense
que voilà
on pourrait vous parler après sans nous
sans nous
alors il y a je vous donne la parole
après madame Berthol donc je
[Musique]
pour répondre sur les jeunesse allez-y
alors
sur la non non sur la jeunesse il y a
bien sûr faire venir des jeunes
Ukrainiens en France mais il y a aussi
possibilité pour nous collectivités
territoriales de montrer à nos
homologues en Ukraine comment sont
construites nos politiques jeunesse
alors monsieur le Président disait que
la France n'est pas tout à fait
exemplaire dans certaines villes il y a
des politiques jeunesse
au niveau national peut-être un peu
moins depuis un certain temps mais en
tout cas dans certaines villes et
collectivités il y a des politiques
jeunesse assez innovantes et nous avons
reçu récemment une délégation par
exemple de travailleurs sociaux du crâne
à Strasbourg au centre européen de la
jeunesse qui est rattaché au Conseil de
l'Europe encore une fois pour montrer
nos politiques jeunesse et comment on
les met en place voilà donc il y a des
choses toutes simples d'échanges de
pratique aussi qui sont aussi alors
encore une prise de parole de
Monsieur le vice-président de la Région
de Tcherkassy qui est encore en ligne
qui a demandé à s'exprimer sur la
question jeunesse aussi
monsieur le vice-président
je vous remercie cette possibilité en
effet les situations avec la jeunesse
est extrêmement difficile car de manière
générale le niveau d'éducation en
Ukraine tombe en ce moment les dernières
examens de bac notamment et surtout au
niveau des étudiants donc très dans
l'université montre que le niveau
d'éducation a baissé d'une part en
raison de la pandémie puisque les cours
ont été faits en ligne et puis lorsque
la guerre a commencé les enfants ont dû
soit être déplacés soit être donc
constamment dans les dans les abris à
cause des bombardements des frappes donc
les cours en ligne n'ont pas toujours pu
être assurés donc nous avons besoin de
des échanges notamment pour tous ceux
qui ont des syndromes post-traumatiques
il est important de trouver ce modèle de
coopération de pratique afin de voir
comment ça se passe dans les régions
français ce qui est très important pour
l'Ukraine car chez nous dans la région
notre cher cassis il y a 50000 de
personnes déplacées toutes les écoles
sont pleines avec les enfants qui font
leurs études dans notre région
aujourd'hui ces enfants intègrent les
écoles supérieures et nous espérons
enfin ils espèrent et nous aussi qu'il
est auront l'éducation supérieure nous
avons également une coopération avec
l'Union des Femmes ukrainienne
d'Amérique qui ont accepté de 13 États
américains collectent des petites
bourses pour les étudiants les écoliers
ce sont des petites sommes mais ce sont
des motivations pour les étudiants pour
les écoliers d'avoir ces sortes de
bourse qui seront payées par les
sponsors privés
ce n'est pas des grosses sommes mais
j'ai vu les yeux des enfants qui
recevaient des mini bourses et ça les
permettait de revivre c'est souvent les
enfants des
soldats morts de ceux qui ont disparu
donc je vous propose peut-être de Didier
cette éventualité nous sommes ouverts à
la coopération je vous remercie
bien nous arrivons au final et je vais
demander peut-être à Françoise de venir
aux pupitre pour le final
merci merci monsieur le président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Présidents
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
chers élus locaux chers collègues
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs Mesdames et
Messieurs les représentants
d'associations de collectivités
territoriales mesdames et messieurs
permettez-moi tout d'abord d'adresser en
notre nom à tous mes plus sincères
remerciements au président du Sénat pour
l'accueil de cette importante
manifestation qui témoignent une
nouvelle fois du soutien au peuple
ukrainien et à ce beau pays merci à
notre collègue Roger caoutchi qui a
ouvert cette séance je salue notre
collègue Nadia ce logo présidente à la
sable du groupe d'amitié France
Ukraine je n'oublie pas Jean-François
Rapin qui est président de la commission
des affaires européennes et qui a
présidé cette table ronde et je veux sal
deux autres collègues Bruno Belin qui
était là tout à l'heure mais qui a dû
rejoindre la séance et notre collègue
Leconte et je pensais beaucoup à lui
pendant cet après-midi parce que notre
collègue le compte qui est sénateur des
Français de l'étranger vit en Pologne et
la situation que vit aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine et le soutien que le peuple
français tout entier apporte à l'Ukraine
me fait penser à ces temps extrêmement
difficiles que la Pologne a aussi connu
elle a emprunté un chemin de réussite
que nous saluons aujourd'hui et que je
souhaite qu'il en soit de même pour
l'Ukraine au terme de cet après-midi le
président
rapalla dit il m'envient donc l'honneur
de conclure cette table ronde qui nous
aura permis de mesurer l'ampleur la
richesse de l'investissement des
collectivités territoriales françaises
aux côtés de leurs homologues
ukrainienne dans cette guerre
d'agression qui frappe aussi durement et
aussi violemment acteur très engagé en
soutien de l'Ukraine le président
l'archet l'a rappelé dans son message
d'introduction le Sénat est aussi
mobilisé pour appuyer la coopération
décentralisée et la délégation
collectivité territoriale et à la
décentralisation du schéma que j'ai
l'honneur de présider est également
extrêmement attaché à étudier l'action
internationale des collectivités
territoriales françaises mais aussi à
s'inspirer de leçons de décentralisation
que nous pouvons
tirer de chacune de nos rencontres et je
crois que l'Ukraine a aussi beaucoup à
nous apprendre à cet instant si vous me
le permettez je voulais remercier
chaleureusement notre nom à tous
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur du crâne et les
élus Ukrainiens qui nous ont fait
l'honneur de cette manifestation votre
combat pour que vive la démocratie
ukrainienne notamment au niveau local
mérite tout notre respect notre soutien
et notre amitié et soyez assurés que
nous sommes auprès de vous cette table
ronde avait pour but de mettre en valeur
les différentes initiatives portées par
les collectivités territoriales
françaises en faveur de l'Ukraine de
donner la parole ainsi qu'à leur
représentant afin de partager des
expériences des réussites mais aussi
des difficultés de comprendre également
la nature des besoins des collectivités
ukrainiennes des besoins qui évoluent au
fur et à mesure que la guerre se
poursuit nous avons eu tout au long de
l'après-midi de très précieux
témoignages que je salue et je remercie
vraiment tous les élus locaux
responsables d'association et
d'institutions qui ont répondu à
l'invitation du Sénat aujourd'hui alors
voici venu le temps de l'exercice
délicate de la synthèse parce que c'est
un peu enflux tendu puisque
la table ronde vient de se terminer et
je voudrais tout d'abord saluer
l'extraordinaire capacité de résilience
de nos partenaires
Ukrainiens résilience qui nous
impressionne beaucoup plongée dans une
guerre si violente et si inacceptable
mais qui continue malgré tout avec
courage une détermination je le disais
qu'il nous impressionne de faire face à
la situation quotidienne mais aussi
envisager l'avenir car ils doivent tout
à la fois répondre aux besoins
urgents des populations mais aussi quand
une affaire vivre la démocratie locale
et envisager je lisais la reconstruction
de leur pays je retiens également de nos
échanges c'était l'un de solidarité qui
a réuni en France des collectivités de
toutes tailles de tout bord politique
grâce à la mobilisation
le locomot mais aussi et je tiens à leur
rendre hommage aux administrations
locales de nombreuses actions
extrêmement concrètes ont pu être
engagés avec un impact réel sur le
terrain et je crois nos amis craignant
l'ont dit c'est ce dont ils ont un
besoin
urgent permettez-moi de citer par
exemple l'envoi dès le 6 mars d'un
premier convoi humanitaire partie de la
ville de Strasbourg à destination de
l'Ukraine pour acheminer des vives des
médicaments et des matériels d'urgence
aux Ukrainiens sous les bons Bruges la
Lozère qui dès le 25 février s'est
engagé dans l'accueil des réfugiés en
partenariat avec l'Ambassade du crâne en
France et l'association Caritas Pologne
pour sécuriser car il le fallait un
premier convoi vers la frontière
ukrainienne le conseil départemental de
Lozère à spontanément voter une
enveloppe de 50000 euros pour financer
des actions à venir je pense aussi aux
nombreuses communes qui on fait le choix
de développer des jumelins avec des
communes ukrainiennes pour affirmer dans
des partenariats il y a bilatéraux
renouvelés leur attachement et leur
solidarité avec la cause ukrainienne les
témoignages de cet après-midi on part
ailleurs montré que les initiatives
développées à titre bilatéral souvent de
manière
spontanée comme la générosité ont été
complétées par un cadre plus probable
dans trade par la coordination d'acteurs
gouvernementaux et associatifs dont il
convient de saluer l'engagement c'est le
cas notamment de la collecte en
seulement quelques semaines de 8000
tonnes de matériel et d'être pour
l'Ukraine grâce au don et à l'engagement
des bénévoles de la Protection civile
l'établissement d'un centre d'accueil au
Bourget pour plus de 600 personnes en
seulement 48 heures mais également à
Strasbourg et partout en France quelques
villes comme Bourges La Rochelle ou
sauce sont particulièrement distinguer
ce sont aussi ses actions qui ont
conduit à l'envoi de plusieurs dizaines
voire centaines de générateurs en
Ukraine elles ont permis aux Ukrainiens
de passer l'hiver malgré des frappes
russes particulièrement cruelles qui
n'ont eu de 16 et non toujours de 16 de
toucher les infrastructures civiles
notre collègue Nadia solo parle et le
dit ainsi le soutien c'est un soutien à
deux temps un soutien d'abord celui de
l'urgence mais aussi le soutien du temps
long jusqu'à l'achèvement de la
reconstruction et nos collectivités
territoriales françaises et les
associations on fait la démonstration
que c'était l'an de solidarité sera
amener à se poursuivre je le disais dans
le temps plus long qui sera celui de la
reconstruction et de son achèvement
plusieurs initiatives sont déjà lancées
avec l'appui de la Chambre de commerce
et d'industrie
franco-ukrainienne et de business France
nouvelles forces pour suivre dans le
temps dans le temps long pour favoriser
l'intégration des enfants étudiants et
réfugiés ukrainiens et nous avons eu un
exemple absolument extraordinaire de
réussite et d'intégration par cette
réussite au bac d'un jeune homme
ukrainien et l'apprentissage du français
qui se développe s'agissant de la
reconstru de la reconstruction les
collectivités les citoyens bénévolent ou
associations sont pleinement impliquées
dans un chantier que la Banque mondiale
annonce déjà comme l'un des plus grands
longs écoute chantier du 21e siècle
alors bien sûr il demeure compliqué de
dresser un panorama
exhaustif de toutes ces actions
initiatives mais cet effort de
cartographie n'en demeure pas moins
essentielle afin de donner de la
cohérence aux interventions d'identifier
les acteurs impliqués sur différents
domaines de développer les synergies et
de les structurer je salue le travail de
la délégation pour l'action extérieure
des collectivités territoriales et de
son délégué l'ambassadeur guillaumé dans
cet objectif pour conclure mesdames et
messieurs je forme le vœu que nos
travaux de cet après-midi permettent
effectivement de donner à toutes ces
initiatives locales et nationales la
visibilité qu'elle mérite qu'elle
pourront nous ne pouvons que le
souhaiter susciter de nouveaux
engagements développés de nouveaux
partenariats au profit de nos amis
Ukrainiens la tâche est immense et
l'action de nos collectivités de leurs
associations
s'inscrit naturellement dans un cadre
plus global mais chacun est un peu le
colibri de la solidarité de la réussite
nous savons que beaucoup d'initiatives
nationales et transnationales se déploie
et ses interactions également été mises
en avant aujourd'hui au travers de cette
manifestation si importante qui nous
réunis aujourd'hui le Sénat a souhaité
apporter sa pierre à cette édifice il a
voulu une nouvelle fois témoigner de
tout son soutien de son amitié
profonde et sincère au peuple crinien et
assez gouvernants le temps d'aujourd'hui
et celui de la solidarité de la
coopération concrète et très active mais
c'est aussi le temps qui tisse un lien
indélébile entre nos deux peuples et le
temps d'aujourd'hui est aussi celui de
la confiance et de l'espérance d'un
avenir européen partagé et solidaire je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
bien merci à tous au final c'est conclu
et
rentrez bien pour ceux qui reprennent le
train ou qui rentre à distance et merci
à nos collègues Ukrainiens d'être restés
jusqu'à la fin
là-bas